Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. No else.
You posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism
living this year.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton,
which I've been using
probably for about a year now.
Peloton is a cutting edge indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home. You can also
do on demand, which is what I do.
We'll come back to that so you don't have
to worry about fitting classes into a
busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute. I, for instance,
have a Peloton bike right in my master
bedroom at home and it's one of the first
things I do. Many mornings I
wake up and meditate for a bit.
Then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
in my undies. Hard to do that at the gym,
take a shower and I'm in higher
gear for the rest of the day.
It's really convenient and has become
something that I look forward to.
So you have a lot of options
for one if you'd like,
you can ride live with thousands of
other writers across the country on an
interactive leaderboard
to keep him motivated.
There are also up to 14 new classes added
everyday with more than 8,000 classes
on demand and you can pick
based on length, 45 minutes,
20 minutes, whatever music,
hip hop, rock and roll or say low impact
versus high intensity or interval.
You can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case I
quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on demand and listened to a lot of and
watch many of the same
classes over and over,
but I'm kind of promiscuous and also
enjoy classes from a lot of the other
instructors.
They have Peloton and amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles
and personalities so you
can find what you're in
the mood for.
You also get real time metrics that you
can use to track your performance over
time and that will help, I would say
catalyze you to beat your personal best.
Now that all sounds good, right?
Gamification, Yada, Yada, Yada.
I didn't think that it would work
for me or in any way incentivize me,
but they really 100% hit the
nail on the head. I was very,
very impressed with how motivating it
was and it worked tremendously to keep me
pushing a, which quite honestly takes
a fair amount. I can get quite lazy,
particularly with anything
that edges on endurance,
which is kind of more than five reps
of anything for me. So check it out.
Discover this cutting edge indoor cycling
bike that brings a studio experience
right to your home Peloton is
offering listeners to this podcast,
a limited time offer.
Go to one peloton.com that's o,
n e Peloton p e l o t o
n.com and enter the code Tim,
all caps at checkout and get $100 off
of accessories with your policy on bike
purchase. So get a great workout at
home anytime you want. Check it out.
Go to one peloton.com and use
the code Tim to get started.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which has the largest selection
of audio books on the planet.
I've used audible for many years and I've
several audio books to recommend right
off the bat. If you're looking for a new
one ready player, one by Ernest Cline,
you may have heard of it.
The Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite collection
of letters of all time as well as the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
which is a fiction book I
use to reintroduce nonfiction
purists to the beauty
and truth and enjoyment,
affection, the graveyard book.
It is incredible and I like the
version that Neil reads himself,
but the entire ensemble cast is also fun.
Audible members get a credit every month,
good for any audio book in the store,
regardless of price and unused
credits roll over to the next month.
So if he didn't like your audio book,
no problem. You can exchange it,
no questions asked. Plus, your books
are yours to keep with audible.
You can go back and relisten anytime,
even if you cancel your membership.
And for some books, again, graveyard book
by Neil Gaiman, I've listened to many,
many times. She may even just start over
as soon as you finish it the first time.
Audible also helps you to listen to more
books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices.
Picking up exactly where you left off,
whether it's on your phone,
through your car,
from a tablet or at home on
an Amazon Echo, whatever.
You can get through tons of books,
hands and eyes free while
doing almost anything.
So that is part of the beauty of audio.
It is a secondary activity when
you're walking the dog cooking,
whatever it might be.
Audible content includes an
unmatched selection of audiobooks,
original audio shows, news, comedy,
and much more from leading audio book
publishers, Broadcasters, Entertainers,
magazine and newspaper publishers
and business information providers.
Maybe that's what I am,
a business information provider.
And right now audible is offering
listeners of this podcast a free audiobook
with a 30 day trial memberships.
Check it out.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim and
browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs. Download a title free and
start listening. It is super simple.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim or
text Tim to 500 500 on your telephone to
get started today.
Check it out.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct
world class performers,
people who are the best at what they do,
to tease out the routines,
the life lessons, the
habits, the favorite books,
whatever it might be that you can
hopefully apply and test in your own life.
My guest today is Paul Stamets.
Hundreds,
maybe thousands of people have
requested that I have Paul on the show.
You can find them on Instagram,
Facebook and youtube. Paul Stamets, s.
T. A. M. E. T. S. He is an intellectual
and industry leader in the habitat,
medicinal use and production of fungi.
That's if you end GI fungi.
Some people say,
and you might also think
of mycelium or mushrooms,
part of his mission is to deepen our
understanding of and respect for the
organisms that literally exist under
every footstep taken on this path of life.
This episode is bonkers.
Uh,
the implications,
applications,
medicinal uses of many of the things that
he'll discuss are truly mind boggling.
And we do get into some of my favorite
subjects, including psychedelics and,
uh,
other aspects of bending reality.
Here we go back to the bio.
Paul is the author of six books,
including my psyllium running subtitle,
how mushrooms can help save the world
growing gourmet and medicinal mushrooms
and siliciden mushrooms of the world.
He has discovered and named numerous
new species of psilocybin mushrooms,
psilocybin mushrooms, or a
solution be mushrooms, uh,
better known as magic mushrooms and
is the founder and owner of fungi,
perfectee, makers of the host
defense mushroom supplement line.
And a little known fact. I have
been using host defense, uh,
products for a few years now after some
mean no Surat said that one of them was
her favorite purchase of less than a
hundred dollars in the last year or two.
And that was in my last book,
tribe of mentors.
So I do have some familiarity
with his products.
Paul has received numerous awards
including invention ambassador for the
American Association for
the Advancement of Science,
the national mycologist award from the
North American Mycological Association
and the Gordon and Tino Wasson award
from the Mycological Society of America.
His Instagram is awesome if you
want to see some really, really,
really weird fungi and him off in the
woods all over the world doing weird
things.
And in a very new and breaking news,
we were actually holding the
podcast waiting for this to happen.
Paul is the author of a new study
in nature, scientific reports,
which details how mushroom extracts
specifically extracts from woodland a poly
pore.
Mushrooms can greatly reduce viruses
that contribute to bee colony collapse.
This is a huge, huge, huge deal.
And we do get into the importance
of bees and how without bees,
pretty much everything goes down the
toilet I including a lot of humanity.
So I will include a
link in the show notes,
which you can always find
at tim.blog/podcast for
everyone who wants to check
that out.
And two other announcements if you are
interested as I am and I'm certainly
committed to this,
to the tune of seven figures over the
next year or two to supporting psychedelic
science and research. Uh, please join me.
And if you're interested in doing
so at a higher dollar amount,
meaning over a hundred thousand dollars,
please go to tim.blog forward slash
science that's tim.blog forward size
science.
And
if
you
want
to
support@alowerdollaramountsacheckoutmaps.org
and
for
anyone
who is already filled out that form,
I will be reaching out soon.
There's a lot of amazing stuff on the
horizon that I hope you will be involved
with.
And the last but not least,
the blog now contains transcripts
of every podcast episode.
To date. People have been asking
for this for a long, long time.
I wanted to do it right.
So now you can find transcripts to
every episode of the podcast at Tim Dot.
Blog, forward slash, transcripts,
and that is a long intro.
So without further ado,
please enjoy this wide ranging
conversation with Paul Stamets.
And if you can only listen to one part,
jump ahead about 49 minutes or so.
49 minutes and 50 seconds I believe.
But yeah,
let's call it 49 minutes to listen to
his description of his first experience
with solicit the mushrooms or psilocybin
containing mushrooms and the effect it
had on his lifelong stutter.
It is fucking nuts.
So if you're going to skip around,
jumped ahead 49 minutes or so and
listen to that story. It is really,
really wild. So they have it. Enjoy.
Paul, welcome to the show. Thank
you, Tim. I'm honored to be here.
I've had so many listeners
requests you on the show.
I have wanted to have you on
the show for so many years.
And finally when you made your very
comprehensive cameo and Michael Pollan's
most recent book that served as the
reminder that I had to reach out somehow.
So I'm very pleased that you're here
and I thought we could start with some
definitions and pronunciation, which, uh,
are very selfishly points of
insecurity for me. So F, U, N, G, I,
how should we pronounce that?
Well, that's an excellent question. Um,
fungi according to Oxford English
dictionary with a j is the correct
pronunciation but fun,
fun, fun guy or fungi.
So fungi is,
what else am my colleges use?
A though people Spanish mycologists
we'll use one g Italian mycologists we'll
say phone g. Uh, but uh, English speakers.
The standard pronunciation
is fungi with a J.
Fungi.
And then there are two terms that I
suspect may not be totally synonymous.
We have mushrooms and
mycelium or Mycelium,
I don't know the correct pronunciation.
Are Mushrooms a subset of mycelium?
One component part. Can you define or
distinguish those two for us please?
The mycelium is the underground network
analogous to the roots of a tree, uh,
and the fruit bodies,
the mushrooms.
So they are produced as a reproductive
structures long after many challenges on
the path of growth, uh, in the wood
and woods underground, et cetera.
The mycelial networks are vast.
It's been called the
proverbial tip of the iceberg.
But just think of this
as the, the mycelium, um,
navigates through microbially
hostile environment.
Literally there can be tens of millions
of microbes per gram of soil and the
mycelial, these five find filaments
that look like cobwebs, um, are,
are running underground.
And this underground network is being
challenged by all sorts of microbes.
And as many people know that
bacteria like to eat fungi.
That's why mushrooms rot.
Um,
but the fungi are able to navigate with
these mycelial networks only one cell
wall thick and there can be up to
eight miles of mycelium per cubic inch.
And now they only have one cell wall
between uh, their, their internal,
uh,
cells and the external environment.
We have five or six skin layers
that protect us from infection.
The mycelium that basically has one cell
layer and yet is able to overcome the
challenges of millions of microbes,
many of which want to consume it.
And it navigates to create the largest
organism on this planet is a Mycelial Mat
and eastern Oregon over
2100 acres in size.
Now it's one cell wall thick, and yet
it's the largest organism on this planet.
And that's the testimonial
to the immunological power
of the mycelium and this
vast underground network, uh, that
is so essential to habitat and human.
And plant health is something
that we have really tapped into.
So mushrooms come from mycelium.
The mycelium can grow literally for
decades before a single mushroom farms.
Mushrooms are highly perishable.
They're like fish and four or five days
they mature and, and then they rot.
And then in doing so,
they spoilery late just before they rot
and they attract insects that are then
help spread the spores. Much like,
you know, birds spread seeds,
um, and the birds come to
fruit. The fruit of the tree,
like a peach for instance,
attracts insects and birds and then the
peach pit or seeds of an apple or what
other fruit are spread. So the fragments
of the mushrooms are beacons, fragrance,
beacons, the MNA through the
ecosystem and the scent trails.
And entice animals to come to these
bodacious Lee delicious fruit bodies.
And then they presented in the
course of them eating them.
They spread the spores. But the
mycelium literally can be existent,
not, not invisible, invisible to us,
ridiculously stupid humans that are
thundering giants upon these networks that
are underneath their feet.
But the mycelium really racist behind
us and we're the biggest walking
catastrophe that I know in the planet.
And as we walk, we break wood chips,
we leave impressions or the Mycelium is
sensitive to those impressions of our
footsteps.
And as we create new debris fields and
mycelium reaches up behind our footsteps
to gobble up that newly made
material and competition,
but other fungi and other
organisms and Mycelium,
if we're looking at mycelium and uh,
as one
component of that or rather not the,
the product of that I suppose.
And please feel free to
correct me if I am fine.
Screw things up by restating mushrooms.
People have had a decent amount of
exposure to and they tend to associate it
with, say, the produce
aisle in a grocery store.
And think of them perhaps as plants,
uh,
from a genetic perspective or
an evolutionary perspective,
how should people think about mycelium?
I love this question. Well, you
bring up a very good point for,
for almost a hundred years now,
the mycology departments where
a subset of botany departments,
they really should be in the
zoo. All logy departments. Uh,
we separated from fungi about 650 million
years ago is 650 million years ago we
had a common ancestor.
In fact,
there's a new super kingdom called a
pilot content that joins fungi and animals
Aaliyah together when basically
the my fiddle network,
um, when, uh, when they hit
the land from the ocean,
many people don't realize some of the
largest networks of mycelium in the world.
Now I've been discovered,
uh,
in below the sediment layers of the ocean
is vast myself on networks throughout
the entire ocean. There's lots
of dead organic plant material.
This falling down to the sediments and
the mycelium is involved in gobbling
those up. But from an evolutionary
point of view, I 650 million years ago,
we chose the path of in circulating our
nutrients, basically in a cellular sac,
stomach,
the mycelium digest nutrients externally
if it is the enzymes and acids and
other compounds that breakdown complex
organic molecules and then absorbs those,
uh, through the cell walls.
The entire mycelial network,
um, is like a sponge.
It absorbs selectively.
There's nutrients that
it needs and animals, uh,
went sort of overground and we did
all these digestive systems and I in a
protective, uh, skin, uh,
enveloped structure or bodies.
Uh, and then the mycelium
continued on us of course,
very happily developing underground.
So with the divergence of fungi and
animals is extremely well documented.
But an ordinary article came
out just this past year.
Um, and this article, you know, the, the,
the big bang was about
13.8 billion years ago.
The earth formed around
4.5 billion years ago.
Uh, the first unicellular organisms, uh,
were found them a few
hundred million years later,
but the first multicellular organisms so
far found the oldest one is 2.4 billion
years ago, but has found
that South African lava, uh,
in the basalt and as
2.4 billion years old,
the oldest representation so far
in the fossil record of a organism,
and these are a mycelial networks.
So the mycelium had its form
long before we've had ours.
And moreover in Brazil,
150,
115 million years ago,
this is before the,
the great extinction event that
killed off the dinosaurs. Um,
and at that time machines
also had their forms.
So these mushrooms are
really ancient organisms.
They had developed reforms long
before we had developed ours.
We are descendant from
these fungal networks. Um,
they are progenitor ancestors.
We are,
we are really descendants of fungi.
This is why under the microscope,
so many of our cells,
it looks so similar to that of a fungi.
And also why our best antibiotics that
we have coming from fungi are very good
at preventing bacteria from growing.
But we have very,
very few good antifungal antibiotics
because of our close evolutionary history
that are not toxic or highly toxic to us.
So antifungal drugs are
extremely dangerous. Um,
those who've had immunosuppressants
are well aware of this. Um, and um,
when you defeat the immune system and
the human body using Immuno suppressants
for a organ transplants
and other, uh, reasons and,
and medicine you really,
um,
dancing with death because it's extremely
damaging to your immune system that
can hold many of these infections at bay.
There's so many directions
that I want to go with this.
I'm going to try to contain my,
uh,
add and focus this in a direction towards
another type of utility and relates to
a problem that if I were to walk 15 feet,
I could observe with my own eyes
right now. And that is carpenter ants.
And I was wondering if you could talk
about your history with carpenter ants and
the intersection with mycelium.
Um, is a subject very dear
to my heart. So, well let me,
I'm gonna I'm gonna Segue,
um,
because there could be listeners out
there who have children and I'm going to
tell their children to the story how
vacuuming and helping your mother and your
parents made me over a million dollars.
And it ties in the carpenter ants. So,
um, I grew up in, so I'm gonna, I'm,
I need two minutes to set
this up in the world. Okay.
So I grew up in a small town
in Ohio, Columbiana, Ohio,
a very conservative town,
about 5,000 people.
Um,
and I grew up in a
fairly wealthy household.
My family had steel mills and
saw mills and we were affluent.
Um,
we had 400 people in the town under
unemployment of a town of about 5,000.
Um, so the stem is enterprise
company. Unfortunately,
because of after World War Two, we
bombed, you know, we bombed Japan,
we bombed Germany, but they
retooled. They rebuilt,
their factory said modern factories
after the war. Um, in the United States.
We didn't do that.
And so the machine tool industry
really fell apart in the early 1960s.
There's a huge economic downturn.
And so I was,
the best experience of my life was
the fact that I grew up in a wealthy
environment.
And then when I was 10 or 11 years of age,
the entire financial empire collapsed.
We lost everything and we laid off over
400 people in the town were laid off.
I'm going to school these, these
kids and their parents, you know,
or not very happy about
what was happening.
It was really a devastating to us.
And my parents separated.
We lived in this big house.
Electricity was cut off,
the water was cut off. Um,
I remember eating cat food. I was just so
hungry, gave me tremendous parts. Uh, but,
uh, but I, my mom was really desperate.
My brother John went on to Yale.
My brother bill was that Cornell.
Um, and um, this is, you know,
towards the end of their
college experiences.
And I was their home alone with
my mother and my twin brother.
And I just really had to step up the
plate and help my mother as much as
possible. I remember running
a hose from my neighbors,
so about 500 feet of hose just to get
two or three psi so we could trickle feed
into the toilet so we can flush them.
It was really strange in the
lead bewildering sort of,
um, Kafkaesque existence because
we were shunned by the town.
My mother went into religion,
my dad went into alcohol.
They both were a self
medicating and essentially,
and where there's those two avenues.
Um,
but I got really good at
helping my mom vacuum, um,
because she didn't help and
we didn't have, you know,
the support team we had any more.
So I was always like tearing apart
vacuum cleaners and borrowing parts and
trying to get, get and trying
to help my mom. Anyway, I quit.
So I vacuum doc and doc here and I got,
I'm really still passionate
about vacuuming this one of my,
I'm a really good house husband.
I like washing dishes and vacuuming a lot.
So how this word segues into the
carpenter ants is the following.
So I grew up in an affluent environment.
It came out to Washington state,
became the logger hippie for three years,
working in the woods, then moved
outside of Olympia, Washington.
I went to the Evergreen state college
and I tried to start this little business
and I lived in a house and a Dr Andrew
Weil said is the worst house he's ever
seen anyone live in, in North
America. Um, that's one statement.
It was a flat flat house built with
military surplus materials and I had 12
buckets catching water from the flat roof.
Why you need to build a flat roof in
Washington state with army surplus
materials.
This is another question,
but there's so many leaks that I just
keep on putting up buckets. And then, um,
one day I remember there's a storm and,
and the,
the house fell like two or three
inches in. My wife does, my God,
the house is falling. I
said, don't worry dear.
We don't have to fill the buckets as
much because the water will rot faster.
I was just trying to be able
to be optimistic because
I was afraid that she was
the one to get up and leave me
because the conditions were so bad.
But any aisle I would be making my
espresso in the morning. And um,
and I looked over in the corner and
there's a pile of sawdust from carpenter
rats and I see them running
around and the carpenter,
carpenter ants are more nocturnal
than they are active in the daytime.
And so I'd make my espresso every morning.
I look over the palace,
Sata supportive.
I come clean or vacuum it up.
I did the next day and the next day and
the next day I'd do this for hundreds of
days. Realizing the house is getting
more, less structurally song, uh,
w with a carpenter ants and punching them.
And so I was not going to do something
about this. And so, you know,
I didn't want to use raid. I didn't
want to use toxic insecticides. Um,
cause the war against nature,
uh,
in my mind is a war against
your own biology and it was
toxic to other organisms
is likely toxic to you. And this has been
well founded now with lots of examples.
So I wanted to environmental protection
agency homepage and I looked up a group
of fungi that would attack and these
are called entimopathogenic fungi now.
So mouthful but antimony maids,
insects and pathogenic means of
course causing disease of insects.
And this group of entimopathogenic a fungi
that was particularly of interest and
supported by scientific literature and
with the encouragement of the EPA was a
group of fungi in the genus [inaudible].
So Metta and rising,
you know, uh, lots of Mycelium,
lots of rice from works.
And so I looked into this group
of men, a matter of Islam, fungi,
non toxic to bees, non toxic
to fish, nontoxic to humans.
Um, and I, I got some of these fungi
and it started growing them out.
Now I started studying this.
Well, this is really interesting.
Why isn't this not available everywhere,
right?
Why isn't there Lowe's and Home Depot and
Walmart? Why aren't they selling this?
Well, for very good reason,
the insects aren't stupid. Um,
when you see insects like the carpenter
ants and are constantly cleaning
themselves,
they're trying to get the spores of the
fungus off of them is the most common
fungus according to some reports
in the soil underneath your feet.
It is everywhere. It is a dance of, of,
of dinner and death between insects
and fungi. Many insects eat fungi.
Many fungi eat insects.
Um,
the two of them don't like to be at
this dinner table at the same time.
So I ended up getting this
fungus and I studied it.
And the reason why it never came to market
is for the spore repellency property.
Now this is really important because
these insects have realized that the scent
of these spores meant that there's
a disease threat to the colony.
So the insects fastidiously
clean themselves of these spores.
So when the big companies like bear and
Dow and Syngenta and tried to make bait
stations using these spores,
even though in the laboratory that
can dust the insects of the spores,
and sure enough, five days later they
would kill the insects. Um, the human,
they put made bait stations
around people's houses.
The insects won't go near those base
stations because there's saw the spores.
And so the spore repellency property
prevented these bait traps from going into
market for preventing a termites,
firearms, Carpenter ants, uh,
moisture rounds, all sorts of, uh, ants
and termites are infected by these, these,
these, this spoilating fungus
matter. Elysium. So I thought, well,
I'm having a laboratory and
a very large laboratories.
We produce about 50,000
kilos of mycelium of the, of,
of many different, uh, gourmet
and medicinal mushrooms per week.
And my environments are
class 100 clean rooms.
These are high tech clean room
environments using heap, Hepa filters,
high efficiency,
particularly air filters. Um,
and the last thing I wanted to spoil,
letting mold in my laboratories.
So I got these cultures and I was shocked
at how many spores they world remind
somebody of a penicillium
mold growing on cheese.
Do you want that flying
around your laboratory?
Because my oyster mushroom cultures
or my sheet talky cultures could,
could become contaminated
from airborne spores. So I,
I cultured this out really quickly.
And so the window of exposure was very
short and I set up all these precautions
and then culturing these fungi and
then they grow out as green molds.
And then I saw this white wedge,
the shape wedge that was all white.
It had no spoilation on it. And
I went, Whoa, that's interesting.
I look up in scientific
literature and everybody said, Oh,
the culture is losing the ability to
reproduce and is losing the ability to
spoil your late.
It is sunesson avoid sectors.
This is what they're called.
These wedges are white sectors
because that path of genetic,
a path down that gene trail will end
up meaning the culture will die and the
parsley got that right.
But I was motivated by not
having sports in my laboratory.
So I chased those white sectors and they
grow out and about a week or two weeks
on then on a standard size petri dish.
And then after about five or six,
seven transfers,
that white wedge got bigger and bigger
and bigger and pretty soon no spoilation.
And this is current day in your,
the,
this experiment that you were running
was, is, is done more recently,
not when you were under the,
the flat roof built by military surplus,
is that right? I'm just trying to put up,
no, this is, this is a synchronous with
that, with a flat roof. Okay. Got It.
So,
but I,
I had to go out in my laboratory to
have enough mycelium and be able to,
to treat the carpenter ants.
Gotcha. So anyhow, so I've,
I finally grew it out and I grew it on
and rice and I made a big deal to my
daughter.
Um,
and I am so thankful to her for the
reasons you're about to hear. Um,
and I made a big deal in the middle of
summer saying we're going to trick the
carpenter rounds because every
morning I'm sucking up all those us.
And so I asked her for Barbie doll dish,
which I still have,
I'm going to mount it in a frame
and I put like 25 kernels of,
of white mycelium on rice,
Elysium fungus without spores because
they wouldn't go near the rice if it had
spores.
And I laid it out at about eight 30
at night in the summer afternoon,
summer evening. And I made a big deal
of it. And it got my daughter involved,
you know, as a citizen scientists
young, she was only, oh my gosh,
she was probably 14 at the time.
And so we, and then we went to bed.
So thankfully my daughter woke up at
102 o'clock in the morning and she,
rather than going
straight to the bathroom,
you see one look at her Barbie doll dish.
She went over there talking to license,
swarming with carpenter ants. Like, oh
my gosh, you've gotta be kidding. And uh,
and so she ran into our bedrooms,
said, uh, dad, dusty, wake up,
you've got to see this.
And you know,
we didn't want to wake up as
two o'clock in the morning,
but she dragged us out of bed and we
went over there and it was just covered
with carbon or rants or picking up
the rice and they're going into the,
into the recesses of the house
disappearing and like, oh my God,
that was amazing because I
hadn't mice in the house,
the mice could have eaten the
rice and I would never have known.
But we watched for a few minutes and
they took away all the myceliated rice.
So we fast forward,
I'm making my espresso every morning,
hundreds of times I get
the vacuum cleaner out.
I go to that spot and
there's no sought us,
the carpenter ants or gone.
And I went, oh my gosh,
I just think I figured out a way to
overcome the spore repellency property.
So now this has been elaborated.
We published an article in the journal,
sociobiology proving this was effective
against subterranean termites.
Formosan termites. We've done
experiments is now in the Usda, uh,
and other, uh, teams,
some of the biggest pesticide
companies in the world. Um,
I'd have to check my NDAs to see
if they're still covered or not.
But everyone listening,
you can imagine who they are.
They tested this is effective
against bedbugs ants,
termites, uh, thrips flies, mosquitoes,
um, you know, uh,
mites phenomenal reach.
And so I ended up finding something that
is a super attractant and basically the
opposite of the spore repellency property
is the mycelial attract unsee property.
Two sides of the same coin,
the ying and Yang of nature.
It's kind of harmonious and that sense.
I like that.
And we found that if we
diluted the mycelial extracts
on rice without the spores,
this, these continual, these preclinical
pre spoilating sectors that I described,
we end up creating a super attractive,
so powerful that when they attracted was
diluted 500 to one with water diluting
the extract, made it more potent in terms
of attract, unsee it. One experiment,
two drops of this on a pane of
glass and fire ants, uh, uh,
locked directly to that place and
scratched at that place until they died
walking about a meter,
uh,
creating a trail that other
than a fire ants would follow.
So that we have done this now
with choices are called t tests.
We've known this was the
t test or even better,
a t test oftentimes is go left for the
control go right from the treatment.
But we ended up doing four and five choice
experiments where there was only one
corridor or avenue that had the treatment
and the other ones were all controls.
Uh, so highly significant activity.
And we found something that I can,
my dream is to be able to,
uh,
to attract a locust plague
into a 55 gallon drum and
we can put these in foggers
and you know, in Africa and
just create a massive, huge,
a huge attractor NC factor.
The cool thing also is they attract
and C is not lethal. Um, so, um, that,
that, that comes later, the
infectious state of the mycelium,
it grows and then it penetrates the,
the Exoskeleton with a Hyphal peg.
It kind of anchors itself like sticky
little tongue and then it dissolves
exoskeleton,
the Chitin and then the Hypo peg
invades into the body of the insect.
And mummify is them.
So these are many people have
heard about these Zombie fungi.
This is what they are.
Uh,
some of them have a cordyceps
representation is a little club,
fungi and Costa Rica and elsewhere
in the subtropics, the, um,
um,
many of the ants there are well known
for the leaf cutter ants and other ants
are known that they have to
get infected with this fungus.
They climb to the top canopy of the
trees and they locked her mandible
underneath the leaf and bullying a
mushroom comes out of their head and their
anus, uh, and a sport lights in
this way, the fungus gets us sporty,
late and free air conditions
high up in the canopy.
So it causes uncontrolled behavior
of climbing with these insects.
So this item,
it's breakthrough and the reason why,
and I ended up licensing in this to a
group of investors and I got $1 million.
And, uh, so I like to
tell my daughter, um,
she was very instrumental in this and,
um,
the licensing agreement
had some limits on it.
They had to take it to
market within five years.
I pulled back to the licensing agreement.
Um, and they didn't take it the market.
So I pulled it back and everything
is actually quite friendly. Um,
but it's a little bit of a mystery
why he did not make it to market. Um,
and I have a lot of conspiracy theories
as to why I did not make it to market.
Um, I hesitate to mention those. Um,
but I was given a chunk of change and
I was smart enough to realize that they
can't crush this and that was a condition.
This has to come to market
but doesn't come to market.
Then I get the patent rights back and
now I've been issued a nine patents on
this. People can go to the u s
patent homepage and look them up.
The latest patent that was issued on
this two years ago is really phenomenal
because I have patents on the antiviral
properties of mycelium and have these
patents on these entimopathogenic
fungi were all insects in all diseases
vectored by in sucks.
It doesn't get bigger than that.
Are there any types of, and um, uh, there,
there are a number of different areas
I want to dig deeper. Are there,
are there any particular common viruses
or particularly lethal viruses that
you've seen applications
for using mycelium
in terms of resistance or defeating?
Yeah, well, there's there, there's
a lot of examples of that. Um,
and so I published an article
and a journal peer reviewed
journal called Herbal
Graham and in June of 2001 summarizing a,
all the literature that's
been published on the,
on the antiviral properties of mushroom
mycelium is a whopping one page long
with like six references. The
virtually very, very little out there.
Well that was in June of 2001
September 11th, 2001, you know,
nine 11 occurred very quickly.
The greatest concern for the
US Defense Department and,
and biosecurity was a
weapon izable viruses, uh,
pox viruses, you know,
anthrax is a bacteria.
The anthrax attacks
occurred a few weeks later,
a group of researchers in the US Defense
Department where scabbing Jane the
literature saw my article and I said,
wow, there's some evidence here.
And they contacted me because I
had a very large, large library.
Now it may sound large to
people who don't have libraries.
I have about 800 strains of a
different species of mushrooms, Co,
many of which collected from
the old growth forest. Uh,
it's now some libraries have
20,000, you know, uh, culture.
So I'm small compared to them, but I'm
private. I'm not a big institution.
And so they said, well, listen, you've,
you've probably some interesting
articles here. There's some evidence.
We have been this, the fund funded by
Dick Cheney and George George Bush.
Ironically,
I have a debt of gratitude to them
with a bio shield by defense program.
It's called project biodefense, but then
became known as the Bio Shield program.
And so they elicited my support and
then I begin to send them cultures,
mushrooms,
boiled and hot water,
ethanol extracts of the mushrooms and
mycelium that gave rise to the mushrooms,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so I ended up sending out a set
them a hundred of these samples. I mean,
this is for me, this is a coup d'etat.
I have government laboratories,
I'll give me free research,
you know, on my extracts.
And so we started sending these out
and didn't hear from them for awhile.
And, um, and he's realized
there were really disorganized.
It was a new program and I got a colonel,
I love that you mentioned his name.
He worked at Fort Dietrich, you know,
where they have smallpox and you know,
it's a bio bio weapons facility biohazard,
um,
facility.
The US government,
we have the most pathogenic bacteria
and viruses and other disease organisms.
And so I had an MD person who was
my controller it federal express.
One day, you know, about two months
later after I submitted the extracts,
a dumper made this big package of
research reports on anti POCs properties,
smallpox properties of our
extracts. Well, I mean,
going through it and no activity,
no activity.
I get the sample number 78 I activity
against pox viruses and then sample 81
high activity sample 88
high activity. Whoa. I mean,
it's like,
you know,
you're looking at a not effective
and no results in the first 77 pages.
You know, it's pretty disappointing. Then
Bam, I got really excited. So I called my,
I called up my colonel,
uh, Fort Dietrich and,
and I said, these results are amazing.
It's exciting. And he goes, what results?
I got the results that Federal
Express just delivered to me. He goes,
you're not supposed to get
those. I am. I said, well,
I'll make a photocopy and
I'll send them to you.
That he didn't appreciate the humor,
but it was a very,
very bizarre time and some very,
very strange things have occurred,
um,
that at that time.
But we ended up finding that those three
highly active results came from an old
growth mushroom called a guera con.
Now,
Gary Econ is the longest living mushroom
in the world, number one or number two,
some debate about that grows
exclusively in the old growth forest,
northern California, Oregon,
Washington and British Columbia,
and a few Sky Islands in Europe. And,
and um, the outs as the Slovenia,
uh, um, and Austria on large trees,
but it is an indicator species
of an old growth forest.
And those three anti ox results came from
three different separate strains of a
Garrick con than isolated, um, from my
many adventures in the old growth forest.
So whoa,
this has got people very excited.
Now I love to be taken to the
mat. I'm referenced driven. Okay.
So anybody out there is skeptical of this.
You can do two things.
You can Google my name Stamets national
public radio and PR and POCs and you'll
see a vetted press release interview
on National Public Radio with me.
The former deputy director of the FDA
and the head of one of the research
division is about shield
by defense program,
Dr Jack Secrets from Southern
Research University. So,
and then
so because I'm in competition with
Pharma and I'm a lone researcher,
how the Little Company and
um, I thought, well, I'm like,
I checked into this and I already had
this entimopathogenic fungi patents that
were just,
you know,
tremendous achievements because the entire
pesticide industry missed all of that.
Um, so I thought, well, this is
novel. I should protect myself.
So I filed a patent it on a
gear icon against viruses,
uh, particularly pox
viruses, flu viruses, herpes,
these are all the other
results that we received.
These extracts are highly active
against multiple viruses. It's national,
not pox viruses. Quick question for you,
is that prevent for preventative use?
Curator to use both.
What are the applications?
This is Tim where I have to draw the
line, um, because these are in vitro,
in vitro tests with human cells
and taking through three different,
uh,
testing protocols to the point where
the next task is in, uh, in, uh,
in Vivo model, right?
And it was an animal.
So this is the best pharmaceutical drug
discovery that you can go through before
you get to get to go to a living host.
These are living human cells, uh, in,
in vitro, not in Vivo. In Vivo means this,
you know, as small mammal, like
an, uh, uh, a mouse, you know,
a rat, you know, a monkey or, or it
goes into human clinical studies.
So these are vitro testing and to be,
even though we have identified now
the molecules that are active against
smallpox,
we worked with the University
of Mississippi School
of pharmacy under Dr Cmr
Ross.
We did come out and guided fractionation
over many years and we have identified
two new anti POCs molecules,
more potent than side Dapa beer,
which is the preeminent, uh,
comparative antiviral drug
control with less toxicity.
And more efficacy than sendoff at Vera.
But that being said,
there's clearly an upregulation of
the immune system and so what is the
contribution of these molecules versus
upgrading of the immune system is a
combination of both.
Is there a synergism is there's
multiple molecules being engaged,
multiple immune pathways.
This is where you can get lost.
You cannot see the forest for the trees.
If you end up focusing so much on the
mechanisms of action and don't see the
result. If you were infected
with the money's viruses,
you didn't really don't care
about the mechanism of action.
You just wanted to know whether
you can overcome the virus or not.
So we have found the anti epox molecules.
We have not yet found the anti flu
or the anti herpes molecules today.
And I have another really good example
of is specific to your original question.
The mycelium being active against viruses.
Can I pause for one quick second and see.
I have to know what happened after the
lieutenant call because I imagine someone
on his end had to have their head
role for that type of security breach,
mailing FedEx to the wrong place
with those research reports.
What happened after that?
Oh my God,
I don't have to make up these stories.
I don't have to make up any stories
are too good to be true as they are,
but this is what happened.
I was in Canada.
I'm speaking to you right now from
Cortez Island, British Columbia.
I was up here on Cortez Island and one
of my employees called up and said,
Paul, there's a helicopter buzzing around
the laboratories. I go, no big deal.
Helicopters fly over all the time,
and he goes, no, it's really low.
And I go, how low? And he goes, listen.
He puts a cell phone up to the back
of your tongue. I go, well, I go,
what are the numbers on the tail?
He goes,
there are new numbers as a Black Hawk
military helicopter that's right on top of
the laboratories. I go, oh
my God, you're kidding. I go,
and this is right after
we got the pox results.
Right after I talked to the colonel,
you know,
like two weeks later or a week
later. And I said, okay, listen,
shut down the business. I
knew immediately, you know,
the government is going to screw up
here and they're going out there and an
abundance of caution, they're going
to end up overstepping their bounds.
And I said, this is crazy. I've already
been vetted. I've already been permitted.
I've already in dialogue with
these people. Uh, and they,
they're trying to spook me.
I mean, what's going on here?
So I shut down the business at the time,
only had 10 employees.
Now I have a hundred. Um, and I
said, so shut down the business,
give the cultures of Americon
to several of the employees.
I never want to know who has them.
You know,
let's decentralize our
self as a target right now.
And so I shut down the business,
all of the employees left, you know,
and the helicopter is
still buzzing around.
And so the next day I called up pretty
pissed off to the colonel and saying,
what is going on?
You know?
And he got really nervous. Now
he's got two black eyes, right?
They delivered the wrong results,
right, results to the wrong person.
And now that one, you know, he
goes, oh, the government, you know,
on one hand doesn't talk to the other.
And they got over exuberant and you know,
in,
you know,
terrorist got this technology that could
immunize themselves and their credit
and it's like whatever,
you know. So anyhow,
it's funny because I was
going through the airports.
I got five stars on every
single airline ticket.
I joke to my wife, here we go again, I'm
gonna get stopped and searched, you know,
and then after this,
then all those,
those five stars got taken away and I
stream through security to no problem.
But I was obviously suddenly on their
radar because I'm, I'm a nonconventional.
Um, but the fact that
I'm here today, actually,
it makes me more of a pitch
Arctic American than I was before.
So then he,
so this is,
so I found these continents I patent on,
on the Cara con versus these viruses.
I found it in 2004. You can look this
up, go to the u s patent homepage,
you'll see my filing dates.
I filed this patent in 2004.
2009 11 was 2001 so I had to write
to pat and get more research results.
We got lots and lots of positive
results from the Bio Shield program.
I think they, I talked to him when
the researchers last year and he goes,
do you know that we analyzed
2,392 of your samples? Taiwan,
I'm so I didn't have to pay for that.
Um,
but we got about 40 excellent
hits from my 800 or so cultures.
Um, uh, that were surprising. Um,
which has led into I think a paradigm
shifting solution that for many of the
problems that we face today,
but I thought filed this patent in 2004,
2006 is not even on the patent
application or homepage.
Anybody out there who
didn't know about patents.
It's usually six months to a year.
That patent application shows up
at the U S P t o. Dot. Gov website,
US patent and trademark office,
a.gov website.
And it didn't show up. It's over
two years. So I called her hold,
my patent attorney gone,
you know what is going on here?
He gets a hold of the patent office
and the Department of Defense took the
patent out of the patent office
because of national security. I said,
you're kidding. That's kind of a pat
on my back. I was like, wow, really?
You think that's not important?
Um, but I said, that's not right.
So we did an intergovernmental agency
trace and a request and the dod finally
released a patent to
go back into the queue.
And so 10 years after I
submitted a patent application,
folks,
usually two to three years,
you get a ruling 10 years after I
smoothed the pattern, it was approved.
That's a long way as it has a long way.
The good news is,
is there a proven 2014 so I've got 17
years. And the whole thing about patents,
I mean we would not be talking
today if there weren't patents.
People think of patents become
open source after 17 years.
The idea is to reward the inventor,
to incentivize things to come to market
because a patent that is not practiced
is not useful or beneficial to society.
You know,
within that 17 years or outside the 17
years, it has to be brought to market.
There has to be a commercial center.
Patents are awarded for three reasons.
One, no prior art, no evidence.
And then the to victor or
proper literature of anyone
saying is having the same
idea to an obviousness.
You want experts saying, Paul Stamets,
you're full of BS. This will never work.
And so I have a message to all my critics
out there. I want to say thank you.
You've helped me so much in
ways that you did not intend.
But I'm really happy that
some people these days.
And the third is usefulness. So
those three things, no prior art,
contrary to conventional wisdom. You
know, and, and usefulness. And so,
you know, obviously that fits all three
of those categories so that then the, the,
the molecules are, I have not patents
and patented. They're open source.
Hopefully we'll never have a
smallpox epidemic or pandemic again.
And I think that's obviously
it serves a greater good.
So another followup question that, uh,
out of self interest, I'd love to
ask related to the carpenter ants.
So for people who are eager to try
to address something with carpenter,
and specifically,
are there any current recommendations
that you would have,
number one,
and then talking about conventional
or contrary to conventional wisdom?
I think at this point
people are wondering,
how did this guy become so
obsessed with this stuff? Uh,
so I do want to roll back
the clock and talk about,
among other things your stutter,
but first I have to know,
is there anything you would recommend as
it relates to carpenter ants or is it a
waiting game?
Well, they, they test him. A
patent is that it's reproducible.
The EPA and Usda now are allowing this
fungus and food handling facilities,
the first fungus ever to be allowed for
controlling insects and food handling
facilities. It has that safe. The safety,
the safety documents supplied
by the EPA are now, uh,
open source and then public domain.
So the companies that did all the
research proving that this fungus was not
dangerous. Uh, now I released all
of our commercial interest in it.
This train of met [inaudible] called
[inaudible] two is that public domain
strain?
Um,
so what I'm saying is you're not legal
for you to go out and use this and
commercialize it without EPA
administration. Uh, but that Tesla,
the patent is reproducible.
And so all of the methods for
doing this is published. And I'm,
and I'm,
I just submitted my entire portfolio
with all my research on all eight or nine
patents,
all the documentation of all these
companies that have done the research,
you know, in themselves. Um,
and I've submitted to a very,
very well known company that
has an extremely potent, uh,
insecticide that many people
know that use it on the market.
And as the word I got back is why would
we want to disrupt a proven profit wheel
is something that we,
my aunts did not reinvented for 10 years
because after the ants were killed,
the carpenter ants,
they sporulated.
So the spore repellency property
prevented future invasions.
That's not a very good economic model
when you can treat a house once and they
don't come back a far better economic
business plan is having consumer buying it
every month and spraying toxic
chemicals that killed the workers,
but don't kill the queen.
The whole,
the whole key to this is the
mycelium is taken back into the nest.
Like a Trojan horse is presented to the
queen who then presents to the brood and
they're all living in this honey.
This sort of my ciliated uh, um,
um, uh, a palace. Uh,
and then before they realize it,
it's sporty lates and it kills the queen.
They can kill the queen.
You can control call the
colony after a spoiler lace.
The spore repellency property prevents
other were carpenter ants from coming
into your house. So it's a 10
year solution for about 25 cents.
Um, that's what it costs to produce. Of
course, the packaging and all that stuff.
You'd add up the numbers pretty quickly,
but is incredibly,
it's very inexpensive to produce and
it can be produced in huge quantities.
So it did not make it to market.
And I, I, I'm exasperated.
Um,
I one really great story on this that
this woman named Chris and that works for
a company that has three
letters in their name. She was,
she was given the mandate because of the
stockholders were really upset because
of the reputation of this company causing
toxic spills that harmed thousands of
people and they wanted it to grow green
movement. Can you find green solutions?
She was given the mandate to find a green
solution to replace toxic insecticides.
He says, given a budget. And she
found me, we dialogue for months.
I gave her samples,
she set up experiments to the
researchers who were so excited.
They called me up at home
and both of them said,
I'm not supposed to be telling you this,
but this is the most exciting thing
we've ever seen in our life. You know,
as as as entomologist and
fighting these problems,
she went to the board of directors
are the priority, were going, we,
we connected whenever the data
together and messaging, you know,
how to create, you know, the most clear
communication to the board of directors,
all men. And she was a steal at Magnolia,
Magnolia. I've never met her in person.
I wanted to hire her immediately.
She ran these, these,
these meetings just so professionally
and she was really excited and she went,
go down and the next day in the afternoon,
I'm waiting for her call and she calls
and the person on the phone is so angry.
I'm going, who is this? And I
go, this is Chris. She goes,
I'm so angry. I can't see
straight. I go, I mean,
she's totally composed before and
she's lost her composure. I go, Chris,
what happened? She goes, I went
in there, I made my presentation,
all men and looked at me
steely-eyed and she said,
this is the best you gave me this mandate.
I have found something.
It's a game changer. They can, again,
we can come with an ecologically rational
and sustainable solution based on
nature.
Um,
and they looked at her and a dour face
and then the chairman of the company
looked at her and said, Chris, you're
a budget. Never was in research.
It was an advertising,
very much similar to BP,
beyond petroleum.
How much of the BPS budget actually is
an alternative fuels versus how much is
an oil?
Now,
how much of their advertising budget is
in alternative fuels as opposed so oil,
I mean, clearly it's called
greenwashing. And um, and so, so that,
that was, and that just so that, that
happened like seven or eight years ago.
And then this past month I just
had the same thing happen again.
It's a disruptive technology.
It rocks the apple cart in many of
these insecticides are coming from the
petroleum industry as byproducts
from their waste material.
So,
so I want to talk disruptive and something
challenging to the status quo and
contrary to most conventional wisdom.
But that requires going way,
way back.
And talking a bit about
perhaps your childhood,
which you described in part already,
but when did you develop a stutter and
why don't you still have a stutter?
Uh, when I started stuttering,
when really when I was, um,
probably about five years old, I mean I
started from the time that I could talk,
um,
my family was this fun,
dysfunctional and I've been told that
sometimes the type of stuttering that I
have is that is related to a defect,
um,
and neurological development in
the seventh and eighth months.
That's one possible reason.
But the type of study when I have
anyone seen the king's speech,
I had that and worse.
So I
just could not speak and I'd
find alternative pathways
to trick my brain with a
preposition or adverbial phrase because
your brain gets further ahead in your
mouth, can articulate and then
you become self conscious.
And the type of stutterer
that I am as most observers,
we don't stutter when we sin.
We don't stutter if I start
speaking in that British accent, uh,
or you create an accent and you don't
stutter when you talk to animals.
So it's a very interesting,
it's a,
something that's triggered
by social contact.
And so it was very difficult
for me to date ladies.
They wanted the super jocks,
the self assured men.
And I was a stutterer.
And so I used to always start at the
ground and I found fossils I found
mushrooms on,
but it's very difficult for me now.
I grew up in a small town in Ohio and
my dad was a officer in the air craft
carrier and the intrepid and soda and
World War Two. So after World War Two,
he got the intrepid aircraft carrier
radio and it was in our basement.
And so my brother John, who was
very interested in chemistry, uh,
he created this huge, you know, huge,
like three racks of chemicals, you know,
in the basement and his laboratory.
He had bunsen burners, all sorts of
experiments going on all the time. And,
but he never let me quote unquote play
in laboratory. I can play on the radio.
And I could watch him,
but he's,
my older brother was the
youngest one in my family. So,
and so John went on to Yale,
my brother built on to Cornell and they
left and they left me in this laboratory.
So I, my dream was always to
have a laboratory, you know,
and living in the country and that
kind of what I'm doing now. But John,
when he came back from Yale,
came back with a book
called altered states of
consciousness by Charles tart and
it was an anthology of research articles
on changing your consciousness of them,
either drugs or from
spinning or from dreams.
One of the early books from
years of California at Davis.
So John lent me this book and I said,
Johnny, I'm there like to see it,
but he says it well cause
I'm on break for two weeks,
but I need the book
because part of our class.
So I got this book and I'm just
devouring this book, you know. And,
and John was my hero.
He was my mentor and John went to Mexico
and Columbia came back with incredible
stories of magic mushrooms and
consuming them. You know, I just,
I adored him. Of course I wanted to do
the same. Then it gave me this book.
And so I'm really getting
excited about this,
but my best friend Ryan Snyder
wanted also to read this book.
And so Ryan Goes, can I borrow your
book now? Your Brother's book? I go,
sure you can borrow it,
but I need it back.
And I started to give it back
to me in two or three days.
So several days passed and I asked Ryan
about the book and he hemmed and hawed
and a week later, where's the
book? And he wouldn't respond,
sort of looking at me in the eye
and I always a good sign. Yeah.
So I go, where's my book? And
remember my, my is booking though.
Then two weeks at my vagina, not
pressuring me, Paul, I need that textbook,
you know, as part of the
class stuff, I finally got,
I had got a hold of Ryan and I said,
where is my brother's book?
And my Ryan said, Paul, I can't
give it back to, and I said, why?
So my dad found it and burned it.
I said,
your dad burned my brother's book,
what? He goes, yeah, it was center
to be counterculture and threatening,
you know, to our family, you know,
structure or not. I could not believe it.
I was so upset and I was so apologetic
to my brother who did not take it well,
you know, like last time I'm going
to trust you. They see you then.
So I was really bad and so, so,
but I thought to myself, you know,
if this was so disturbing to
this Alpha Male, you know,
conservative,
you know,
neo-con like personality than I think I
found the subject I'm going to explore
more. So that got me into,
into magic mushrooms and um,
from my experience and also tremendous
amount of guilt for my brother trusted me,
but there's textbook and I
couldn't return it to him.
So John was really interested
in this subject. He inspired me.
And then John went on to chemistry,
then neurophysiology and University
of Washington medical school on full
scholarship.
And I was left in the laboratory.
And so I started
experimenting with marijuana.
I remember the DEA came
to Columbia in Ohio.
They had a whole display of drugs and
a whole bunch of me and my friends just
went there to look at them.
Wow. Wow. Look at that one.
How old were you at the time? 14. 15
years of age. I mean, drugs on display,
drugs you've heard about, you've never
seen. Huh? Look how small that LSC is.
That's incredible.
So I still had this really bad stuttering
habit and it was really socially the
ability dating, um, on multiple levels.
And so I ended up,
and I was in Ohio and I ended up buying
a bag of magic mushrooms and I've never
really into the drug scene,
so I don't know if I know how
much things should cost, you know?
So for 20 bucks I bought a bag and I just,
I knew set and setting
was really important,
but I had no guide and nobody else
in my little circle was into it.
And so there was a really great walk
that I would like to walk in the woods up
on the hills and beautiful rolling
hills and Ohio, northern Ohio. And,
and I thought, okay, sentence I think
is important. So I took the bag and,
and um,
I thought that would be one dose
was not one of those folks.
I probably ate about 20 grams
of a slice of events. US.
Now in defense of this,
I need to make it clear that these were
not grown and these were harvested and
so there were exposed to the sun.
So they may have been on the equivalent
to like 10 grounds of cubensis for
people who are listening,
five grams, that's lots of,
he commences to the hero's journey
and you know, you're full blown.
You're into star scape,
you're changing dimensions,
you're fractal patterns.
The error becomes a sea of mathematical
formulas and your mind is opened up.
Your hearts opened up your feel
one with the universe. That's the,
that's the hero's journey.
That's five grams. You know,
you don't get that until it
was going over three grams.
She started getting into it.
But so 10 to 20 grams is,
is the super hero's journey. I've never
eaten these before. And so I walked,
I was walking into this
place about an hour walk.
I started consuming them and
drinking water because they
were dried. And then, um,
I saw a tree that I love climbing
and this tree had his limb,
so it was a perfect climbing tree
and at the very top of the hill.
So I thought that's a great place. I mean
set and setting a, getting a good view.
That's what I need and I could
feel the mushrooms coming on and I,
as I climbed up the tree, you
know, stem branch by branch,
I got higher and higher. So it was
kind of a ascending euphoria, you know,
that kind of kind of went with everything.
It was very cool.
And I got to the top of the tree and
beautiful landscape and I'm up there and
then just the mushrooms are coming on
and getting higher and higher. And,
and I've realized when I'm really
getting high here and a little dizzying,
so I'm holding onto the
tree and on the horizon.
But this being Black Bank of boiling dark,
angry clouds,
it was a summer storm coming in.
And Ohio,
when you see the summer storms are hurt,
they're terrifying.
They're lightening bolts coming down and
thunder and lightening there was off in
the distance,
but it was coming at me really quickly.
But I'm getting higher and
higher as a thunderstorm.
Lightning storms coming closer and closer.
I'm getting vertigo and I'd go,
oh my God, I, you know, I can't get
off the tree. I don't want to fall.
It's like held on the tree for dear life.
And it became my axis Mundi sort of my
access to write into the earth and I just
an amazing experience. I mean,
just beautiful experience,
but also the threat of lightning coming
closer and closer and every lightning
strike it would hit them,
be fractal patterns would just emanate
out from every lightning striking.
This is a synesthesia occurred, you
know, where there, you know, uh,
it sound and, and, and, and
visions were merging together and,
and um, it sounds, had visions
and visions that sounds,
and it was just an incredibly
complex, you know, the,
one of my favorite books are the
glass bead game by, by Hermann Hessa.
I'll also called a master
Ludy and some other area died.
He got the Nobel prize for
it in 1955. Um, but that,
that was a deep dive into,
into inner space exploration.
But I felt like I was part of the
glass bead game and I, there I was,
I was descending into this higher state
of consciousness and then I realize,
oh my God,
I'm in the highest point in
miles during a lightning storm.
This is not a good place to be.
And uh,
and then I was up there,
I was terrified and the lightning storm
came closer and closer and I had these
can pathogenic, you know, just empathy
for the universe one, everything is fine.
If I die here today,
my life is complete now I understand.
I'm part of the fabric of all
the matter that surround me.
I'm one with everything
I made of stardust.
Everything's made us start us. This is
a continuum of nature. Death is natural,
birth is natural transitions or,
or just the way of way of existence.
And then the lightning
storm and the wind came up.
I'm washed with warm rain
and it was just terrifying.
A lightning storm and I that meant
that there. And I'm thinking, Oh,
I'm going to die, but
if I don't die, Paul,
what are you going to learn from this
experience? Challenge yourself right now.
This is all great and wonderful,
but let's get down to brass tacks.
What's your biggest issues? You're not
going to die? What's your biggest issue?
I stuttering.
So I'm having this dialogue with myself.
I just can't overcome this stuttering
habit, you know, I'm not stupid.
And I went to for people to
understand how bad it was,
I was interviewed for special education
because of my stuttering because I
couldn't read in class. And so
when it's my turn to read, I, I,
they would pass on me because no one
had the patience to hear a stutterer and
please don't finish a or a sentence.
Look at them, smile and engage.
Help them finish their sentence,
don't finish it for them.
That robs them of the opportunity
of overcoming this speech deficits.
Um,
so I scored high on my test,
so I didn't get it put
into special education,
but it was a pretty demoralizing to
realize I'm going to go in to the special
education class. Um, but I didn't.
So I thought stuttering is my issue.
And so I started saying to myself, Paul,
stop stuttering now. You can do this.
You're not stupid in it. Come from a
very smart family. You have, you know,
you can do this. And so I
said, stop stuttering now
over and over and over again.
Hundreds if not thousands of times,
and there's storm washed over me.
I felt like I achieved a state of godhead.
I felt enlightened.
I come from a Christian background.
So I had this empathic empathy with Jesus.
You know, and now you understand
why Jesus went into wilderness.
And I don't understand why Jesus said,
don't go into churches,
go in the nature or whatever. You
know, that's my cultural background.
But I saw it, I connected on that
level and I realized, oh my gosh,
this is something that I can overcome.
So I came out of the tree,
obviously did not get
electric and went back home.
And then the next morning there's this
girl that I greatly admired and she was
super sweet and nice to me and I really
love her to this day because of her
kindness. Um, and,
and I didn't want to talk to
her because every time I talk
I,
you know,
and then you get these half breaths going
on and then you can't get out of this
loop. And, um,
she's coming on the sidewalk and in the
morning and she looks at me and she's so
sweet. He said, good
morning Paul, how are you?
And I cast my eyes up from the sidewalk
and I looked at her and I said,
I'm doing fine,
thank you for asking.
And I stopped stuttering just like that.
Now I do have,
I've had about four or five
relapses, you know, um,
if that's a lot of noise and I've
been drinking and somebody asks me,
how do you grow mushrooms? It's like
filling a well with a teaspoon. I like,
where do I begin? You know, like so,
or if I mean somebody super famous or
something like that, you know, it's,
but that's natural. You know, people get
stage fright, um, when they're, you know,
and so,
but if it's something that I think is
really important because there's one other
aspect there's related to hearing that
I want to mention and I have a really
good friend,
he just passed on now named Bill Webb.
He lived in big Sur California and I
was 19 years old when I wrote my first
book, Salafi mushrooms and their
allies. I was self-trained,
I got involved in University of
Washington with Dr. Daniel Stones,
part of a taxonomic key council.
And I adopted the taxonomy of psilocybin
mushrooms as my special reality.
Yeah. That the time, there's
very little literature on it.
Most of the books in
libraries have been raised.
The pages had been raised it out.
Doctor students had an intact library,
so I could study with them.
I became a taxonomist.
I wrote talks about Mickey's
starting when I was 19 or 20.
And that became the core of my book.
So I'm uh,
have this manuscript and I go to Montana
books in Seattle to pitch the book and
Montana books is pretty soon some,
some gay friendly literature and
they were on the cutting edge.
I was recommended that I see them.
And so I made an appointment,
I go up to Seattle and I'm in a meeting,
the head of Montana books and he goes,
you know, this is not, our
market is an interesting subject.
Really what you need is a book agent and
it goes to the best book agent I know.
Cause Bill Webb and I haven't
seen him in two years.
And at the sounds of those words,
a little bell jingles on the front
door of Montana books in walks,
Bill Webb and the publisher one.
No.
So bill and I became tight friends,
invited me down to big Sur.
He was a friend, uh, of,
uh, of uh, Henry Miller, um,
and um,
and just a really fantastic individually
become a father figure to me at a
really critical time in my life.
And so bill and I did journeys together,
you know, sacred journeys
without any alibi. Obi wan
Kenobi. You're realize I'm 19,
20 years old of age. I'm
with a 75 year old, you know,
who is a friend of Ansell Adams. He
had Ansell, Adams Library of, of uh,
of many of his implants and working
with his wife and curating them.
I mean really cultured intellectually
interesting guy, beautiful place.
And so bill and I tripped several times
and it was a wonderful experience for me
and it brings tears to my eyes
is talking about bill. So bill,
he died about 15 years ago and bill
calls me up about three or four months
before he dies and he goes, Paul, I for
telling you something that's so important.
I'm jealous. I haven't heard from you
in years. How's it going? He goes, well,
frankly, life socks. I've lost losing
my sight. I'm losing my hearing.
I can't hear the waves.
So this equals now I live above the
cliffs of big Sur except for this damn
hearing aid, which has always
malfunctioning. They say, I hate it,
but I've got to tell you something. It's
so important that you know, I go, okay,
Bill. And I said, what is it? Bill goes,
no, I really want you to listen, Paul.
This is important, Bill. I understand.
And then he kind of kept
on emphasizing ends.
And finally I got frustrated and
bill, I got the message, okay,
I know what you're gonna tell me.
It's important because I want to
make sure that you tell other people,
will you promise me? And I go,
I promise you. He said, Paul,
I think I found something medically very
important about Saul Simon. I go, what?
He said, well, you don't run on the
hero's journey. I was, you know,
took out my hearing aid.
I'm laying, you know,
in full bliss and one with the universe.
You know,
he's like 80 years age or 82 years of age
when he was doing this by himself as I
know. I could hear the seagulls, I can
hear the waves. I know, oh my gosh,
I can hear everything. And he reached for
his hearing aid. He didn't have it in.
And he goes, oh my gosh, I can here. And
then he heard this, click, click, click,
click, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap. He looked
around going, that's, that's weird.
It doesn't unusual sound and pick, click,
click, click, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap,
click like. And he goes, he couldn't
figure out what it was. He looked around,
he looked around and
finally he saw what it was.
There are ants walking on the deck
and it was hearing their footsteps.
That is wild. Now this is where even
I, and I'm a liberal kind of guy,
I'm like, wait a second, you know,
tell me that again. You know,
and that's why bill set me up by saying
you have to tell other people this.
So I'm in work working with youth,
with Roland Griffiths at Johns
Johns Hopkins University,
the clinical studies on Psilocybin,
etc. And I am really emphasize this to
the many of the researchers they could
easily do attached, you know, why
these patients are in session, uh,
to test their hearing.
Is He,
if they have increased sensitivity,
increased range, tonal ranges,
is it very easy metric?
But I think what happened with me on the
tree and the lightening storm is that I
created a new neurological pathway of
articulating my thoughts and overcoming
this social phobia.
The social phobia is a trigger is
definitely an environmental trigger.
And then we get locked into these
loops that are really, really strange.
Another good thing to tell a study room
is can you demonstrate different ways of
stuttering?
They'll do it.
You want me to start her
different ways of stuttering?
I'll give you three different ways and
stuttering and it is so it's really weird
because that act as a pattern interrupt
that helps them to overcome at least
temporarily the stuttering or is it just
a useful for a nonstarter order here,
different ways of stuttering.
Hmm.
I haven't thought of that. That's,
I'm not sure how to answer that,
but I do think that once a new
neurological pathways are established,
you can capitalize on them.
Okay,
bye.
Were you remembering them?
And this is the thing that
John Hopkins University,
some of the most surprising results is
14 months after these experiences when
many of the patients said there was the
most important spiritual experiences of
our lives.
14 months afterwards.
Not only they have demonstrated
will benefits being nicer,
people being a better parent,
a better husband,
socially more well adopted.
But the fact that they reremembered the
experience re enforced those benefits
that they experienced
directly after the experience.
So a lot of people,
people are listening may not understand,
these are not drugs of abuse. You eat
these mushrooms one day, the next day,
you'll no way.
I'm mark one near those things.
You look at them and you've got
the repellency property, right?
The psilocybin repellency property.
Like I'm not talking about it for months,
but boy, that was a great
experience. You know,
so these are not substances of abuse,
but there are shockingly powerful to
the point that you're not ready for the
hero's journey for a long time.
So these are not drugs of abuse
by any stretch of the imagination.
They really should be recategorized
as a therapeutic drug.
Definitely. Uh, and this, this
in many ways relates to your,
well,
it relates to a few of your previous
stories very well in so much as a silicide
is very challenging as a medical model in,
in several respects, one of which
is that it does not require, say,
daily or weekly administration.
And it is economically difficult to
create a for profit model unless you are
monetizing a therapy and adjunct pre and
post support and things of that type a
but not in the,
the sort of one and done or three times
and done aspect of it actually makes it
very challenging to commercialize and
make widespread unless you're relating on,
uh, or relying on
donations. Excuse me. Uh,
I would love to hear your thoughts.
Just to expand on this a little bit.
Do you think,
say psilocybin or another that I know
very little about but wanted to discuss
with you, but we can talk about
both or either say lion's Mane,
are there in this case,
should I say mushrooms or should
I say my psyllium or my Cilia?
What would be the right way to art and
we won't be the right term to use here?
Well, yeah, the
mushrooms are like white people know,
is it emerging as a tremendously important
reservoir of many bioactive molecules
that are supersede the
benefit of mushrooms,
25 and whole genome sequencing of
a Reishi mushrooms and the genus.
Again, a Dharma, um, uh, these, uh,
the common links link g lyncher a
ratio of men and talking 10,000 year a
mushroom, the mushroom of
immortality. These are all
common names out of Asia. Um,
they're 25% more genes are active and
expressed and the mycelial form than it
is.
And the fruit body form that they fruit
buys a mushroom form as the end of its
lifecycle.
So much of our research as found going
side by side comparisons of mushrooms,
which are protein rich, uh,
they're a Beta Glucan, a rich,
they have lots of carbohydrates
and then polysaccharides,
they're nutritionally dense.
But the mycelium is,
is articulating constantly I
bio shield of defense and uh,
if I'm the exposure when the mushrooms
form good luck to any bacteria and it's
going to rot it.
It's got to,
it's got to spoilating four or five
days and then gives himself up anyhow.
Moreover,
I think that the sequence of bacteria
that rots mushrooms is absolutely
instrumentally and uh,
important for the evolution of the
ecosystem that give rise to the trees that
create the debris fields
that feed the mycelium.
So these are deterministic
microbiomes and the micro biome,
the,
the fungal is determining
the micro biome because many of these
bacteria are adversarial and some of our
commensal somewhere actually
mutualistic beneficial.
So that mycelium is this articulation
of this network that because of EPA
genesis,
the ability to respond to environmental
stimuli and upregulate and express nude
and gene expressions, it is
a fertile ground for, uh,
learning for being able to articulate
a responses as new challenges and the
environment, the mushroom fruit body is
at the end of the thing. But you know,
people are attracted to mushrooms and
they fear that typically nature of that,
which is a femoral.
Now we're around trees and around
dogs and animals and plants for weeks,
months,
years.
So the familiar either factor of constant
exposure day to day gives us some
confidence and oh that animal
is not going to attack me.
Or that plant is one that my answers have
been using and, and we understand it,
but mushrooms that come up and disappear
in four or five days, some can feed you,
some can kill you,
some can heal you,
some can send you on a psychoactive
journey that which is so powerful,
but so ephemeral is naturally
to be afraid of them.
So we have about 200 species
of mushrooms that are edible,
medicinal. I don't know the difference
between edible and medicinal anymore.
I'm all edible.
Mushrooms have medicinal properties,
but the mycelium expresses a lot more of
these compounds. And with lion's Mane,
there's a group of uh,
Aaron Ne Scenes.
Now the lion's mane mushroom is
called Harris Iom. Erinaceous.
That's the Latin binomial.
Yeah.
Paul,
I don't interrupt,
but I just want to pause for one second
to plant a seed and we can come back to
it or spore and come back to it later,
which is potential applications
to neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's
or Parkinson's.
But I don't want to interrupt.
I just want to plant that seed
so that I don't forget it myself.
So please continue.
So the [inaudible] are some of the
strongest and nerve growth factor is ever
discovered by science.
Ngf factors are called neuroco factors
and they regenerate Myelin on the axons
of nerves. So now lion's
mane is perfectly legal. Um,
it has a long history of use, multi
thousands of years. History of you.
It looks like a, a casket. It looks like
pom poms that cheerleaders shoes. Yes,
a white casket and crystals,
uh, a descending, uh, um,
um, teeth. Um,
and it's a beautifully beautiful mushroom.
It tastes like shrimp or lobster when you
add butter to it and when you cook it.
But the compounds that are most neuro
generative are from the Mycelium,
not from the mushrooms.
And so the era ne scenes are from the
Mycelium Harvison knowns are another group
of Norwest factors there from the
mushrooms, but the [inaudible] is by far,
much more neuro regenerative.
There's been several clinical studies
that have come out on mild cognitive
dysfunction out of Japan.
Um,
and they are very promising isn't as the,
it's the first smart mushroom wall.
Silicide mushrooms, maybe the first
smart mushroom in my mind, but, but,
but lion's mane mushrooms is one
mushroom that I take on a daily basis.
My mother takes it on a daily basis.
She's almost 93 years of age and a
few days. Uh, she's smart as a whip.
She beat my two brothers and
scrabble and not too long ago,
which was a lot of fun.
I went really,
I told them my brother's mom
beat you is gravel, you know,
and my twin brother go low. You
know, she got lucky and I go, oh,
that was a clean wind then who? My
brother was very defensive. But,
but nevertheless,
my,
the lion's Mane Mushrooms I
think are extremely helpful,
uh, to for rent, neuropathies.
And I think stacking them with silicide.
And something I'm really keen on is doing
microdosing of psilocybin stacked with
lion's mane,
the lion's mane in and of itself.
We know as neuro regenerative
properties is a big subject of research.
If you go to pub med or Google
scholar alerts, you know,
put in lion's Mane and neuro regeneration
or an NGF factors and you'll,
you'll,
there's several dozen peer reviewed
articles extensively exploring the
regeneration of Myelin,
which is the conductive sheath on the
axons of nerves and those where I gets
Alzheimer's if for instance,
have amyloid plaque formation
that interrupts in the roads,
the Myelin sheath prevents
neurotransmission.
And so lion's mane mushrooms
have been demonstrated, uh,
behaviorally and people with
cognitive tests, but also,
um, through a dissection of mice, uh,
prior to using lion's mane,
they would inject these mice with a
polypeptide that induces amyloid plaque
formation. It's a very, very potent
toxin. There's neuro neurotoxic,
but mix out of the,
what happens to the nervous system of
Alzheimer's patients because amyloid
plaque formation can be, yeah, it
can conform their behavior changes,
they lose the ability of the navigating
through mazes. They lose the novelty,
inquisitive, and in fact factor, the
short term memory is basically erased,
um, uh, or much of it.
And then when they've had the lion's
Mane Mushrooms and they dissected,
doesn't mice and then sure enough they
saw that the amyloid plaque formation was
there and then there's fully a diseased
mice when they would then feed them
lion's Mane mushroom for 23 days.
They regained the ability of
navigating through maize. They,
we engaged inquisitiveness is
called the novelty, a response,
then all the tea experiment. Um, and
then upon dissecting those knife, uh,
and the resections of the tissue,
they could see that the amyloid plaque
had largely resolved [inaudible] nation
had occurred. And so you
bundle that with, you know,
you've got to behavior as well as physical
evidence of regeneration of Myelin.
So lion's mane mushrooms are,
it's just a very,
very fascinating mushroom I think about
and his last days I think about some of
my mentors and my collegey
and their very last days,
we are losing encyclopedic knowledge.
These are mental giants that have so much
to give to the next generation as part
of our national heritage or intellectual
national heritage. And to lose these,
these geniuses with all this experience,
all this knowledge,
all this sense of being and contexts to
lose them at the end of their life is us
losing a library that just as the library
books fall into pieces in your hands.
And,
and I think it's so important for,
of our culture is to
preserve that knowledge.
And I think lion's mane
mushroom is a huge one.
The slow descent into sort
of cognitive malfunction,
uh,
is,
is what I would site when people
ask me what I'm afraid of.
I mean that that is it.
I mean,
being trapped in your body without the
cognitive capabilities that you would
want or need to not just
function but thrive.
And I completely agree with you.
This is something I've been fixated on
for quite some time. If you were to,
uh,
if you were to design a study involving
the microdosing micro administration of
psilocybin under a proper
supervision and uh,
you know, sort of
researcher controls, what,
do you have any idea what
that might look like?
What the protocol might look like?
Very timely question because in two
hours from now, I have a group of, uh,
uh, of financial people, uh,
that are key in supporting the current
psilocybin research at Johns Hopkins and
elsewhere. Uh, they're arriving here, uh,
specifically and saying with me for
three days to talk about exactly this.
I had an idea and I'm going
to probably open source this.
Sometimes I filed patents, I call them
blocking patents. I filed a patent.
I think she'd be open source in order if
the other people can't get a patent on
it. And this might be
in that category. Um,
it's this whole patent
landscape. I'm, I'm, I,
I see both sides of the arguments of open
sourcing and then also keeping things
close source.
But I found a patent on neurogenesis.
You can look it up and stacking
lion's mane, psilocybin and Niacin,
nicotinic acid. Now, uh, I
spoke before what is patentable.
It is no prior art is speaks
against conventional wisdom. So,
and when I gave a talk at maps, um, uh,
recently I asked the
audience about 800 people.
How many people remember during the
1970s and eighties, it was well known,
especially on the west coast.
If you want to come down from a
bad trip on psilocybin or Lsd,
you could take a bunch of Nice,
then you'll get a hot flush flush and
people who don't know what may take 500
milligrams of Niacin.
You get red and you get tingly all over
your skin and you've got this nice and
flush and now about 50 people raised
their hands. I actually recorded that.
I needed that for my patentability because
that was common knowledge that Niacin
counteract the effects of soul side.
I think not number one,
there's no evidence that that's true,
but it was common knowledge. Number two,
because it excites the nerve endings and
Rob Kathy's oftentimes occur then the
deadening of the nerves at
the fingertips and the toes.
It struck me that if I could
excite the nerve endings,
perhaps I can drive these lion mane
and lion's mane air a scenes and the
psilocybin to the end points
of the nervous systems if
the vascular system still
intact to deliver these compounds
to create neurogenesis. Uh,
and prevent neuropathy, uh, at the
end points of the nervous system.
So I filed a patent,
a stacking Niacin
silicide and lion's mane.
This psilocybin a dosage is about one
20th of a gram now that is below the
threshold of what people would
experience any change in consciousness.
So I know lots of people who would
not dare take us all type of mushroom,
but the idea of taking one 20th below
threshold dose that would create
neurogenesis and perhaps make them
cognitively more astute and make them a
better person. You know,
socially and intellectually.
I knew a lot of people were interested
in that. And plus it's kind of groovy.
It's kind of sexy.
He's older people say their kids,
I'm micro dosing, you
know, my go to thing.
Extremely popular right now as
you probably are well aware,
but that's something that I,
that we would like to see a clinical
study now the clinical stuff we already
know for there,
any conditions out there.
You have too many variables and you're
in your clinical study and I agree.
And so we were looking at silicide alone.
That's a lion's mane alone.
Silicide and stock with,
uh, with lion's mane.
Niacin will have to come later because
it's just you and you need enough
cohorts,
enough people enrolled in the clinical
study in order to have us statistical
significance almost stuttered
there. Um, uh, so that's,
that's what we're looking at is
looking at stocking this and,
and we maybe do this
clinical study in Canada. Uh,
right now the FDA is very favorable
to the clinical studies. I had a,
a report from somebody met with the FDA
regulators and they're scientists and
they said they have never seen
a drug that was so nontoxic,
so effective from one treatment and the
history of they're looking at approving
new drugs. Uh, and they were like,
so the FDA scientists are
quite focused on that.
And it's something we all in different
between medicine and a toxin. This dose,
I wouldn't call it silicide went of toxin.
Well,
there's maybe one,
one funny example that just came out
in the literature of that, but, um,
I wouldn't call it necessarily a toxin,
but having a sub threshold
dose I think makes a
is it is a really valid approach because,
um,
and you probably shouldn't take these
every day because you had normalized their
receptors.
And so Washington said the receptors and
having them recalibrate themselves is
probably a good thing to do.
So pulse therapy,
three to four days on
three to four days off is,
I'm probably a better approach than taking
them every day so that the jury's out
on that and a lot of different
opinions of it, of it. Some,
it's, it's endlessly fascinating though.
And you are right on the, on the money,
so to speak,
or lack of money given how effective
they are in limited number of sessions at
the combination,
which is certainly has been studied in,
is being studied of
efficacy and low toxicity.
Um, and as you mentioned
earlier, if a rat, if you put,
and you know Michael Pollan and I have
chatted about this a little bit in his,
his podcast,
but if you were to administer say
to a rat and a box,
cocaine or heroin and they,
they have to choose between
those drugs or food,
they will consume these types of
opiates or stimulants until they die.
It did to the absence of food.
Whereas with say Lsd,
I would also assume psilocybin,
they,
they take one dose and that's the last
time they touched that particular battle.
And, uh, this is, uh,
I don't want to take us too far field and
focus on this exclusively, but, uh, I,
I really appreciate you having spent so
much time to thinking about how these
natural companions who have coexisted end
of an ingested by humans for thousands
of years can be applied for some of these.
Uh,
that's the epidemic scale problems
that we're experiencing. And, uh,
I wanted to, uh, ask,
we are going to talk about some of the
applications of mushrooms outside of
human medicine,
but I would love to read a
description of you and then it,
it relates to something we were chatting
about a little bit before we started
recording and talk about the decisions
that made Paul Stamets Paul Stamets
because there are so many of
my colleges out there. Uh,
I've certainly don't know the
exact number, but you are,
if not the best known and certainly one
of the best known and the description is
from mother Jones, says, uh, uh,
Paul Stamets is a modern example of the
amateur scientist from the 17th and 18th
century who made a wonderful,
who made wonderful contributions with
only their native curiosity and keen sense
of observation.
And you can certainly comment on that
if you don't feel like it's accurate.
But what, what are the
decisions you made, if any,
come to mind or habits you've
cultivated that have allowed you,
helped you to arrive where
you are? I mean, you, uh,
has made many discoveries, youth, uh,
you've excelled in multiple fields.
Why is that?
How did you become who you
are in this current moment?
And you can start anywhere. I'd want
to be one of the people who asks you,
how do you grow mushrooms
at a cocktail party?
I have been exposed to a circle of
kindness and I believe in Karma.
I was a child who had a lot of problems
and I want a big debt of gratitude to my
professor,
Dr. Michael Buble.
He never humiliated me and not
at the Evergreen State College.
I make some dumb statements.
He was entertained by them,
but it entertaining by them in a
humorous way that engaged me to explore,
you know, um, you know,
in dive more deeply
into the subject matter.
But I was never humiliated
and as a circle of kindness.
And I really believe in Karma
because this isn't meant as,
it has been a huge thing in
my life is the fact that, um,
I believe evolution is an
extension of gratitude and Sharon,
and there's not this
necessarily this, this, um,
neo Darwinian concept of
competition and first to food wins.
It's that collaboration of people who are
allied together with common interests.
And we needed a shepherd,
all of our ourselves from our weaknesses
to become stronger. What very few,
uh, lots of people know this, but very
few different schools that people know.
This. I got into the martial arts
when I was 14. I have two black belts.
I had schools for 30, 40 years. Um,
I have long haired Hippie,
the nice person and I kind of turn
it into a different individual.
I've been in thousands of
fights. Um, I started to aspen,
the category martial arts. I first
got into Goto, she showed con Szeto,
got my first buckle belt in taekwondo,
and then begin on black on one Rango,
which is by far one of the most
sophisticated styles in the world,
similar to have Quito and, and, uh,
some of their styles, Cook School.
But that I had one experience that I
think is emblematic of this is that I was
an early young black belt in
taekwondo and big biker came in.
He was just seething with anger and
wired on fed amines and, and, um,
and he wants to fight a black belt,
you know,
just a biker dude and he's
just pissed off at the world.
And he came in and,
and number that hadn't,
instructor does not fight at a challenge
like this. They have too much to lose.
And you know, if they screw up, you know,
I lose face in front of students. So,
you know, many of them, my,
my head instructor, Jean said
it, Paul, I got another one.
Okay. And, um, so there's
Michael Kamen and,
and then inside Lao lecture,
fight one of my black belts and it's fine.
So Paul come over here. And so I came
over there and was really polite and,
you know, I extend my hand, shook my
hand, and he went to shake my hand.
He just was all piss and vinegar and
wanting to fight me. And I said, well,
we have a few rules. Take
off shoes, you know, um, and,
and then we got out on the mat and this
guy just attacked me for Roche mostly.
I mean, it was, no, no, sort
of like a boxers, you know,
they have a little bit of like,
okay, let's do it. And you know,
we have a little compassion
for each other, you know,
the little simpatico or
another fellow warrior.
Now this guy was like out to hurt
me. That's how I block block, block,
block block and him and this guy is just,
you're just swinging and kicking in
and he can't kick well number one,
but he's just like overly aggressive and,
and you know, after a while, you know,
you can block 10 or 20 times, but you
know, you started getting hurt, right?
You know, these are these guys
just emotionally trying to hurt me.
And so I looked over at the,
my head instructor and he
nodded his head and said,
okay, Paul, time to
take them out, you know,
the three or four punches, you know, um,
sucker punched him, did a jumping hook,
kick, Bam, hit him in the temple,
Bam that he went down on the
ground, you know, semi-conscious.
And then I'm hovering over and
I put my hand onto his trachea.
I put my middle finger into the inside
of his eyeball and that way I could pop
his eyeball and pulling his
trache at the same time.
Now people are really concerned about
their vision and also in their face,
you know,
so the,
when you block your finger into the
eyeball and ready to take out the eyeball,
people want to give up really fast. He
was terrified. He had the look of like,
Oh my God, I'm going to lose
my eyeball and this guy's
got it. You know, he didn't,
he was just waking up from being
stung from this kick, you know?
And I got him like that and I knew
I had to, okay, this is it. No,
I can take him out right now and this is
the end of his life, you know, end up,
you know, basically he's
done. And then I go,
I released, I said, you know,
you actually did really well and
I extended my hand in friendship.
He's laying on the map,
big burly biker guy started
crying because I was nice to him.
I took him down but I
wasn't glorifying and my,
when I was extending my hand
in friendship changed his life.
When I left the school, he was a brown
belt. He became this big teddy bear.
You shepherding. Yeah. All these little,
I told him, listen, this girl here,
she's got a yellow belt. You've
got a white belt, you bow to her.
That's the way it works here.
Just based on your experience and respect.
Totally changed his life.
So,
so that's a story of my life is
that you know the extension of,
and I think siliciden mushrooms
make people nicer people.
I just really believe that there is
this understanding that your life is not
just your life,
your life is in the context of nature
and how are we going to do inspire and
lead and promote the forces of good and
generosity and mutualism and how are we
going to get away from the people who
want to tear it all down by my work with
bees I think is is the,
is the cost of lab of my life and we're
definitely going to dig into that.
I absolutely want to explore
it.
I was just going to echo what you said
about the power of kindness.
A friend of mine,
very good friend of mine was just
telling me recently who perhaps not
surprisingly has a lot of
psychonautic experience. Uh,
it's mileage with, uh, certain
mushrooms that we've been discussing.
And also for anyone who
doesn't know what maps is,
it's the multidisciplinary association
of Psychedelic Studies. They're also, uh,
focused,
very heavily on phase three trials
for MDA in the treatment of Ptsd.
Uh, which is, is fascinating
and I encourage people to
take a look at that at,
at maps.work. But what my friend
said to me is not too long ago,
several weeks ago, he went
into a coffee shop, uh,
and it was some Dunkin donuts or
something like that in an airport.
And this woman said,
thank you at the end of the transaction.
And he looked at her in the
eyes and he said, no, thank you.
And he was just kind of being a
joker and he's a charming guy,
but he meant it very sincerely
and she just broke down crying.
Similar experience.
Like she had not had,
didn't seem anyone express kindness
to her and God knows how long,
I mean weeks, months. Who knows? And it,
it just was such a stark reminder,
just like your story about the power of
those little acts as tiny little micro
decisions that we all make
thousands of times a day.
And that's what, you know,
I have a business, you know,
but anybody who was ordered from
our business, I own the business.
So I run it and I had several years ago
I got these little stickers that say you
are beautiful.
And every time someone orders from
our business and their order are too,
you are beautiful stickers.
And I've had so many people right
saying there was just a horrible day,
a physician or just wrote
recently he had said, oh my God,
I cannot believe this little messaging I
sent too because then they can pass one
forward. So every order and
every box there are two.
You are beautiful stickers.
And so many people have written saying
that's what they needed to see that
changed their entire day. That again, an
extension of gratitude and affirmation.
You know,
and we are all on this planet together.
We lifted live in this time and space.
Tim, you're going to die. I'm gonna die.
Everybody listening to this podcast
is going to die. But we ran,
we enter into the fabric of
nature from which we sprung.
And I think that fabric an Hra is
based on the extension of goodness.
I just know it empirically and all
the noise we have around politics and
everything else is just
so narrowly focused in the
context of the greater being.
I think that we're on the verge of where
science and spirituality are converging
and now we're understanding nature
and the extent of the cosmos,
the hundreds of billions of
galaxies. I mean just, um,
I always wanted to be an astro mycologist.
I kind of am now in some sense,
but I've always wanted to, I think we'll
find fungal networks throughout nature,
throughout the universe,
on multiple planets.
Multicellular organisms
will form is networks.
Networks will give rise to animals.
And I think that the,
we are a descendant of this network based
paradigm that's represented not only
and mycelium and a neurons,
the computer internet.
The Organization of the dark matter.
This is a continuum and a
keen continuation on different
orders of magnitude of
the way of being.
We are all involved in this network of
being and this is just one of our strands
in that network that we're living today.
And I want to get to bees and I'm going
to get to it by way of laying out some
illustrations of these,
these webs,
these strands of interconnectedness.
And this is from discover
magazine from a few years back.
And I'm just going to quote here,
it'll take 30 to 60 seconds probably.
And then I want to talk about bees
specifically. Uh, it starts with this,
and this is a very incomplete
list of course, but stem is,
is researching a wide variety of ways
in which fungi could help solve human
problems. Here's a partial list.
One, environmental cleanup.
Mushrooms could be used to break down
petrochemicals or observe radiation from
contaminated soil and water
to wastewater filtration.
A mushroom Mycelia could cleanse runoff
from storm grims farms or log logging
roads. They can be used to
filter out the nitrates,
endocrine disruptors and pharmaceutical
residues that disrupt ecosystems and
damaged human health.
Three pesticides,
fungal bug killers or treat discuss could
be used to target troublesome species
while remaining nontoxic to other four
medicines which we've we've discussed
could provide new antibiotic,
antiviral,
and immune boosting compounds
and even chemotherapies.
Five forestry planting symbiotic mushroom
species could speed reforestation and
clearcut woodlands. Six
agriculture adding, Ooh,
this is the word that I can
never pronounce. Adding Myc, o.
R. R. A. H. E. A. L. How
do, how do we say that?
Microrisal microrisal thank you.
Adding microrisal fungi to soil could
improve crop yields without the need for
toxic chemical fertilizers.
Seven famine relief.
Mushrooms can be grown rapidly in refugee
camps in disaster zones using just
woodchips or salt water soaked Straw.
Eight biofuels growing mushrooms for
biodiesel could require far less soil and
other resources and commonly
cultivated fueled crops.
Nine which segues to what
we were just chatting about.
Space travel because of their usefulness
and soil creation and the tolerance of
many species for radiation.
Mushrooms could be grown by interstellar
voyagers and use to terraform other
worlds. So I'm going to pause here
for one second just to let people,
so in that and then second in both
preparation for this conversation but also
over the last two years reading various
descriptions of what has been called the
the Wood Wide Web I think is
what they call it, the, you know,
the mycelium and how they facilitate
communication between trees and other
organisms. It's really mind
bending stuff. I mean it's, it's,
it's the type of narrative and description
and discovery that if described,
I'm just making this up perhaps,
but like 50 years ago would have
been thought science fiction and uh,
I would love for you to describe what
you have done in the world of bees,
but I just find this so not
only staggeringly fascinating
and much of it counter
intuitive but important. Um, so that's my,
that's my soapbox for the moment.
But then in any case, would,
would love you to take
that wherever you'd like.
Okay. Well I would recommend that
people read my book, mycelium running,
how mushrooms can help save the world.
It covers into these subjects a very,
very deeply, um, and,
and a book is using it now as an
introductory mycology book had many
universities.
Um,
I typically don't promote
a product from stage. He,
there's no lectures out there.
You can find this,
but I do want to draw people's attention
to fungi.com [inaudible] dot com
there's an amazing letter from a
Syrian refugee. And I want people,
we obscured his face because we don't
want him to be targeted by Assad Assad's
assassins.
Uh,
but he has brought in mushroom cultivation
and in refugee camps using recyclable
materials from the cardboard and
all the paper. And he literally,
you have to read the letter to it
just brings tears to your eyes.
He's over a thousand people now
engaged in growing mushrooms,
oyster mushrooms and
refugee camps, and then, uh,
from the Syrian crisis that are
helping people feed themselves. And,
um,
and um,
think about all of those thousand people
now understanding how to grow mushrooms,
what the downstream effect will be with
their children when they get out of this
camps. They'll have skillsets that can
really expand this. And in a huge way.
Um,
I believe that mycelium is the
foundation of the food web.
It is essential for food biosecurity.
I mentioned that the mycelium
creates the micro biomes.
We've done next gen sequencing
and we've been able to prove this.
I have not published it,
but people can see my talks on it
showing that different mycelium Mycelial,
mass control and uh,
destined populations of bacteria are
uniquely specific to the mycelium that had
growing, uh, in, in, uh,
wood chips are in Straw.
And so they actually articulate the
populations and bacteria a downstream from
the mycelial networks. But this is
going to segue. So we talked about the,
the antiviral stuff and over the bio
shield bio defense program and nine 11.
Well, and I had this entimopathogenic
fungi patents and they're working against
termites,
carpenter ants and bedbugs and mice.
And so a good friend of mine,
Louie Schwartzberg,
he actually has finished a movie called
fantastic fungi is coming out in the
next few months. We've been
making it for over 10 years, um,
with a linear Lynn Lear,
Norman Lear,
and isn't that group. And the,
I just saw the final cut, um,
a few days ago. It is quite good. I'm
really happy we're where it's going,
but it talks about the wood wide web
and Susan's Tamara is a British Columbia
mycologists and I'm a total fan of her
work and in a big Kudos to her because
she and I are two peas in a pod and she
was doing her work parallel to my doing
mine and, and we ended up, you know,
really and the, and the, the same, uh,
intellectual ecosystem so to speak.
Um,
but so when Louie was doing a movie and
he was looking at butterflies and then
he got into bees and Connie claps and
colony collapse is really a client.
Claps disordered is a
euphemism created by the media,
but it does speak to a very serious issue.
Um,
and Oklahoma last year,
74% of the beehives died.
I'll think of it.
If you were having a cattle or sheep
at your ranch and you lost 75%,
or is your sheep are accountable.
That is devastating.
Let's also devastating to beekeepers.
Um,
35% or more of our food is directly
dependent upon bee pollination.
70% is indirect.
Many people don't realize that most of
our dairy products are dependent upon bee
pollination because I'll fall flat
and hey, it depended upon bees.
All the almonds that you consume,
every one almond that you consume
was visited by a B on that flower.
And so the almond industry specifically
needs honey bees in particular.
And so, and then Louie
came and he said, Paul,
this is a huge problem with colony
collapse and bees are dying.
What can you do about it?
Well,
I had a series of events,
um,
and these events,
when you string them together and
led to me and to an epiphany and the,
I am a controversial mycologist.
I have been trained academically in
Mycology as an undergraduate student.
But I married a woman 11 years
older than me who had three kids,
a 12, 14, and 16. When I was 22,
I couldn't afford to move my kids to
other cities to go to graduate school.
I got accepted into several graduate
schools, but I couldn't afford to move.
So I started this little
mail order business impact
30,000 boxes before I had a
single employee.
Now I have over a hundred employees.
So it's a real testimonial to stamina
and good luck and also the extension of
generosity by some very kind people who
came to my rescue a few times over my
life. But in the course of looking at, uh,
at the situation with bees,
I started looking at it and there's,
there's many cofactors now,
health or disease in my mind is a
series of coefficient variables.
Factors which are strung together at
the end of the equation means health or
disease.
So there's not a single cause for
colony collapse is a perfect storm of
unfortunately bad things are
happening to the bees habitat loss one
neonicotinoids we already know
they'd been banned in Europe,
ironically from a study that Berenson
Genesis sponsored thinking that neo nics
would not be toxic and they found out they
were toxic and so they were abandoned.
Europe last month. Mnemonics are still
used in the United States and Canada.
Um, these, there's so many, 70%
of the food has talked to me. Uh,
absolutely critically dependent
upon bee pollination services.
You know, um, two arms length away
from direct bee pollination contact.
So bees are dying because of a confluence
of variables. Last Hub, habitat,
neo nics, pesticide exposure, factory
farming. It's not natural for me.
It's been put on trucks and traveled a
thousand miles to the almond orchards of
California. They all are
concentrated. They spread
diseases amongst themselves. Uh,
and then they disperse. And so it's
a, that's the great, great, uh,
scenario for diseases be spread.
But by far,
the biggest one that's been identified
in the scientific literature is the
Varroa Mite. The Varroa mite was
introduced in 1987. It came from Asia.
Varroa destructor assessed this
Latin by no do I know the binomial.
It injects a whole slew of
viruses into the bees. And these,
uh,
these now all bees in the world have
these viruses working with the USDA,
Dr Jay Evans and a,
it was a USDA neurologist who's widely
published in a senior scientists at the
Usda ag has not seen a virus
Freebie more than 10 years.
What's happened now is a virus that's
being spread by the Varroa mite.
The Varroa Mite was controlled by might
aside that was used to control ticks on
cattle called amtrust.
Now Amma tries is not legal to use
by beekeepers, but they use it.
They were soaking their beehives
with this. Emma is toxic,
you know,
tick might aside and they're drenching
it twice per year to control the Mites
and now they're up to eight
times per year. Within 10 years,
the Mites have developed a resistance.
The mites are like having a pancake
on your back. They attach themselves,
are extremely hard to dislodge.
And now 27 viruses have been
identified being vectored by Mike.
What's the big surprises?
All the wild bees now have these viruses
and 80% of the pollination services
that we benefit from, from
bees pollinating are actually
coming from wild bees,
not the honeybee, which is
[inaudible], which is a huge colony.
So the wild bees are oftentimes called
solitary bees are very small groups of a
dozen B's or two dozen
bees or ground dwellers.
And those bees provide over 80% of the
services that are benefiting a APP called
culture.
So the honeybees demand,
we have about 2 million
hives and the United States,
the average loss right now
is over 50% nationally.
A few hot spots where there's hot spots
then emanate out and epidemics become
pandemics. And so now we have
evolved into a viral pandemic, uh,
of these viruses spreading
throughout the world.
And it was just discovered
in the past two year,
three years that these bees are
infected with these viruses.
When they visit a flower and
they get the pollen on them,
they also spread the viruses to the palm.
They leave.
And so when the wild bees come,
they become infected.
So this is a direct threat to
worldwide food biosecurity.
The loss of bees is such an important
issue in interestingly is the number one
bridge issue between liberals and
conservatives. So I like to delve even Ui,
thanksgiving dinner. You don't want
to talk about Hillary or Trump.
Talk about the importance of bees is the
number one issue that brings liberals
and conservatives together
because everyone recognizes
the importance of bees.
Uh,
as it is for food biosecurity.
So my friend Louis came to
me and I started studying
this subject and I had five
experiences in row that
led to me to an epiphany.
And no matter what my critics say,
and I, you know, I've been wrong,
sometimes I'm not right all the time,
so I accept that,
but I pushed the envelope because
I don't have to worry about tenure.
I'm self employed.
I can risk to be wrong.
But the more I speculate,
the more I test,
the more I do research, you
know, that's what it takes.
It takes the efforts to
see if something will work.
And so I failed a lot of times in
the failures, the price of tuition.
I paid to learn a new lesson. All
that being said, this is what happened
in 1984 I had the garden giant
mushroom growing in my garden.
It's a wood chip mushroom that grows
in wood chips, prisons, mushrooms,
up to five pounds per specimen. People
can look it up. Um, and I had these,
which shifts permeated with mycelium and
I have two beehives and one day in July
come out and I see the bees all over my
wood chips and I looked really closely
and they're moving the
wood chips to aside,
it's like you pushing a semi
truck through side some of these,
which was really big
to expose the mycelium.
I looked very carefully and
from dawn to dusk for 40 days,
there's a continuous convoy of bees
to the my wood chips of the garden.
Giant mycelium in my garden traveling
about 800 to a thousand feet as a,
I went out there, I photographed up,
thank God I found the photographs.
There were Kodachrome 64 slides
and sweltering heat. You know,
two years ago I found him up in the attic.
But I published this
in Harrison's magazine,
1988 I published this in 1994 in
growing gourmet and medicinal mushrooms.
One of my books.
And I speculated,
oh the bees are going after
the sugar rich extra dates.
Cause the mycelium is producing these
polysaccharides that are sweet and they're
fragrant. And maybe that's why the bees
are going there. Okay, that's, that's one.
I'm going to give you a
Michael factorial equation.
So that's the first Michael Factor.
Factor number. Paul sees B's attractive,
the wood chips in his garden,
I forgot about it, Michael.
Factor number two,
Paul gets involved,
the Bio Shield program discovers that
Pauline for mushrooms have antiviral
properties and many patents have issued.
Now I have more patents on this.
People can look them up.
Um,
and so that was another experience that
I had a number three and by getting rid
of the carpenter ranch than my
house Cz entimopathogenic fungus,
we lighten that insects
are vectors of disease.
And then moving forward,
I'm looking at the research articles
and and plus it's an open source,
you know, an online
journal, Scientific Journal.
There's an on the cover of the plus was
a big article on the discovery that Sema
colony collapse happens.
Most people don't know this is that
you got your beehives on Monday.
Everything is fine. You go out there
on Thursday and they're all gone,
they're gone.
It's not like there's a whole bunch of
dead bees lang in front of the beehive.
They're gone.
They fly away.
It turns out that the bees
are the deformed wing virus,
which is the number one virus of concern
that's been identified by researchers.
Almost a dozen papers have been published
in the past three years identifying
the deal.
You've worn deformed wing virus as the
virus that is the most debilitating to
the bees. It normally, we just did
a tensile strength of their wings,
but they're deformed. They can't
fly it all. We see bees on flower,
it's the last days of their life.
These used to go out,
they get pollen for nine days and
now they're going out for four days,
so they can't enough pollen back to
the hive. So the new [inaudible],
which are nurse bees are prematurely
recruited to go out to get pollen because
the colony is stressed and then the
brood as Mites on them and the bees can't
attend to the brute.
They abandoned the babies and the mites
then freely go around injecting these
viruses into the bees.
And so at some point it comes to a
tipping point and then the bees leave the
hive and they don't come back.
So imagine if you were again,
a cattle rancher or a sheep rancher,
he loses more than 50% of your
estate is psychologically damaging.
It's all economically damaging
and people just give up.
So I had these experiences and then I
saw in this journal that when they looked
at the honey and the
abandoned Pete beehives,
it lacked a certain chemical
called peak tumeric acid peak.
Americ acid is the chemical trigger that
governs the detoxification pathway in
bees. It's called the cytochrome p
four 50 pathway. All animals use it.
We have it mostly in our liver
is how we break down toxins.
Without peak Americ acid, they found
these bees hundreds of pounds of honey,
no bs in the beehive. It lacks
essential nutrient peaking Americ acid.
I'm not a chemist, but I'd seen
peak America House and before,
because in the research I've done,
look at what's called the
d lignification of wood,
how fungi gobble up
wood and break it down.
And I recognized he America acid as a
chemical constituent that was present, uh,
in breaking down wood.
And that's why you see my ciliated would,
is smells fragrant and no difference.
There's a lot I outgassing
of chef Michael Flavanoids,
a phenol phenolic compounds
that are going into,
and that's why after a rain and the the
woods, the wood steel, it smells so good.
That's the outgassing of mycelium.
All these sent trails are being created
to entice us in insects and other
animals to follow centrals and part
of the outgassing of the mycelium.
Okay, I had all those four
experiences and then I go to sleep
and I have a waking dream and then it's
waking dream hit me like a lightening
bolt. I said, oh my God, I
woke up, I think. I said,
I think I know how to save the bees.
And so I first called a very good friend
of mine, Lee Stein. I said, listen,
that's how this a waking dream.
I just shook me to the core.
He said, stop everything you're doing.
Focus on this. This is too important.
So call it the universe of California.
Davis is never a good idea
to start a conversation.
But then there are scientists that you're
not, not met with words. I had a dream
that a conversation went nowhere.
It's like crazy person. Goodbye.
So I called the abortion state university.
I was at Ted,
I think I have to Ted that you spoke up.
And I was at Ted and I went out and I
was given Steve Sheppard's name from
Washington University. He's a chair of
entomology in Pullman, Washington, uh,
Washington University's Agricultural
Science College. And I said, listen Steve,
please just give me a half an hour.
It's going to sound crazy to you at first,
but let me talk to you about this.
About 15 minutes. And he said,
stop and go nowhere else.
We want to work with them.
So the end result of this is we tested
this on 532 beehives in southern
California two years ago.
We've done seven tests
now and outdoor beehives.
We have found something.
I think that it's extraordinary
breakthrough with our
mycelial extracts of these
poly pore mushrooms, these, these Woodcox.
They look like they're called him hooked
shaped mushrooms that grow on trees.
Everyone's seen them.
Um,
with the mycelium that's
extracted and water and ethanol,
the very same extracts that we use in
the bowel. You about defense program,
we gave it to the bees and we've submitted
an article to a renowned scientific
journal and from one dose at 1%,
all beekeepers feed sugar water to their
bees is 50% sugar fish without water.
So one milliliter per hundred, you
know, one unit per hundred, 1%,
we give it to the bees in
the seven to 12 days later.
Those viruses are reduced by thousands
of times in the article that we
submitted,
reduced the Lake Sinai virus by more
than 45,000 times the deformed wing virus
by more than 800 times with one dose
and a doubles the lifespan of bees.
Uh,
think of the implications of this.
This means that I think I have a
window now and understanding something
fundamental to the foundation of nature.
The mycelium not only controls a
microbiomes and are deterministic and the
downstream evolution of ecosystems,
but they also control the immunological
health of the animal inhabitants because
the very same extracts that
reduce viruses that harm birds,
bird flu,
h five n one h three h one n
one in pigs that harm people,
pox viruses, herpes viruses, birds,
pigs,
people bs.
This speaks to something I think that is
very deeply profound and understanding
that within nature of these mice,
a little neck and it works everywhere.
Every tree is infused with mycelium.
Every vegetable you eat
is infused with fungi.
This is part of the
mutualistic relationship that
we have with these fungi.
They increases the host defense
of resistance against disease.
There's a plurality of fungi and such
diverse populations that create a matrix
of defense. We have found
that these individual species,
now we've tested five
different poly pore mushrooms.
They're all active but
to do different degrees.
What we have not reported
in the scientific article
that we submitted as that we
have one result,
there's over a hundred million times
reduction of these viruses with one
treatment.
Many of these viruses,
herpes viruses are known as uncle
viruses that cause cancer. Uh,
lots of them caused inflammation
that destabilizes the immune system.
This is something I think
is so critically important.
Everyone's talking about bad news and
we are in the six x the sixth grade
extinction.
Knowing that life on this planet,
we have 8.3 million species with
leaves losing more than 30,000 a year.
Do the math on a hundred years.
That's more than a third of the
biodiversity as unraveling all around us.
What can we do?
This is actionable ecological
solutions as paradigm shifting,
that scalable, ecologically
rational, economically sustainable.
I can all of these fungi grow on every
forest of the world and we all grew up
with Winnie the pooh and
everybody missed this. Now,
I've been issued now 10 patents,
the United States,
Canada, Australia, New
Zealand, and Eurasia.
When I first got the first patent
award for five seconds, I was excited,
literally, and then it became
horribly demoralized. I said,
you've got gotta be kidding. There's
no prior art, no one they did the,
the patent office is the
most massive search engines
and every language, Chinese,
French, Japanese, English, German.
And there's not a single mention anywhere
out there that bees benefit from my
silly,
I mean logically let alone reducing
the viruses that have been vectored by
Mites.
The fact that I'm the one who
discovered this is horribly depressing.
It means that we are,
we're truly neanderthals with nuclear
weapons and people talk about climate
change and biodiversity is a
bunch of liberal scientists.
Are you freaking kidding?
This is so fundamental to who we
are and where we've come from.
So I've opened sourced at the all the
developing countries, but you know,
Europe and Eurasia, um, uh, not, not
Asian, not South American, not Mexico,
Not Africa. You know, in order
for a solution to be effective,
it's got to be practiced in
order for it to be practice,
it's got to be commercially
successful in order.
If we're going to be
commercially successful,
it's got to go to market with
some protection to have your idea.
But the fact out that these
patents are issuing is an,
and I'm, I'm, I made mistakes and there
my colleague out there whose eyes roll,
but I'm very happy to
receive several rewards,
one of which from the Michael [inaudible]
Society of America for bringing more
students in the field of
psychology than anyone in history.
So there are kind of schizophrenia about
me because I'm a psychedelic researcher
and not trained and you are bringing all
of these students into their classrooms.
They want to save the world. And they
said, Paul, you could have a huge problem.
We want to study yeast and these students
want to save the world. What did we do?
So, um, but,
so I think this is something
that is actionable solutions.
And I think I can make the argument,
and this is very provocative,
but I can make the argument that
natural products can be more powerful in
pharmaceuticals with a
greater bio shield of defense,
less toxicity and more
utility in a sustainable way.
And that I think is paradigm shifting.
I hope you're right.
And I look forward to learning more
about this as the discussion opens.
Is there anything for people listening
who are not my cologists nor future
mycologists who want to
help in some fashion,
meaning they want to
make personal decisions,
maybe think of policy changes
or types of support, uh,
that would enable them to be part of an
environmental and a systemic solution
rather than simply compounding the
existing problems or their new behaviors,
things they can do. Anything that you
would suggest to people who are listening?
Absolutely.
I would assemble.
The thing that people can do is let wood
rot give up this idea of there's a beat
then in yard as highly and managed
nature likes fractal faces,
in fact, realization of nature
at different orders of magnitude.
And it gives all these new issues to
microorganisms and microbiome biodiversity
that's critical for sustainability.
So rather than letting,
calling the wood off, having a running
a lot, but let raw logs rot in your,
in your garden and your yard mushrooms
will come up. That'll help feed the bees.
They'll help build these fractally
intense environments that are really
important for biodiversity.
That's one. Uh,
we have a campaign for supporting
Washington state, uh, university, uh,
DVD at Wsu A. Dot. Be a BS. Dot.
wsu.edu.
We've raised over $3 million and
now a four be researched, uh,
at Wsu.
We have just begun to explore the rule
and he's probably per mushrooms. Uh,
there's hundreds of them to test.
Uh,
we've hit the home runs on our very
first ones. We're extremely lucky,
but the fact that, you know, this is,
it speaks to them and we can reduce
these viruses 45,000 to one with one
treatment. I mean, what antiviral
drug will do that, you know,
um, that is a complex
soup of constituents are,
you know, the contrast is this a
surprising, so supporting, uh, uh,
B company B nonprofits
joining a mushroom society.
These,
the North American mycological association
was the apparent Organization for a
called an Ama.
And their website is [inaudible]
dot org and a m Y C O. Dot.
O g. They have a listing of all the
local mycological societies, you know,
and the Canada, United States
and Mexico. Um, that's one, uh,
joining your B and get
involved in supporting frankly
a farmers and developing
biodiverse landscapes and the march
to monoculture and the marsh to the
industrialization of agriculture is
sacrificing the very biodiverse networks
that have evolved to help plants grow.
When you add lots of
fertilizers and insecticides,
you defeat the natural systems of the
mycelium that has engaged and help plants
for hundreds of millions of years.
When you have my psyllium helping plants,
you do not need external kind of can,
puts as much as fertilizers,
et cetera.
And I think there are ecologically
rational solutions to many of the problems
that we face today,
but it's really speaks to the concept
of seven generations and first peoples
really have this so much as a pillar
of their understanding and dealing with
nature.
We shouldn't give up this idea of making
money in the short term and we should
embrace the idea of
creating sustainability.
And the longterm true conservatives
should be conserving natural resources and
thinking about downstream generations.
Right now we have hungry,
greedy people who has,
whose morals have been hijacked.
Um, for whatever reason.
And I think that this,
this nature loving movement
with all of it's strange,
you know, characterizations. Yeah.
It really is based on something that's
fundamentally good for the Commons.
Well,
it makes me think of what you said at
the very beginning of certainly in the
earlier portions of this conversation,
which is the war against nature
is a war against your own biology.
And ultimately what is best for what
you're discussing is also best for us,
which means it's best for me.
It's best for you.
It's best for each
person listening to this.
And certainly if you're thinking
out multiple generations,
these problems can be
solved in a very pragmatic,
holistic fashion. Or they
can be compounded to the
point where they become, uh,
exponentially more difficult
to unwind and to solve for. Uh,
so,
and we just want to stay in the
field of mycology. I have no,
no other science that is underfunded,
underappreciated,
and yet has such an enormous
elasticity of benefits.
And if I was a Bill Gates or Jeff
Bezos and know I met these people,
it's just not part of my DNA to pitch.
And I look at them going,
I could do so much benefit for
hundreds of millions of people,
but I can't even begin to talk about
this because I don't want to pitch.
But thankfully my company
is soaring. And, um,
I'm great group a community
of individuals who are,
who believe in this, who
see the results and, um,
Michael Pollan's book and fantastic
fungi and you know, you're,
you're in support, et cetera. It's to
help spread this message. But, you know,
I'm 63 years of age and I want to die
with a smile on my face because it's a
heritage that we leave,
not,
not the material possessions that
we own during this short lifetime.
We all need to create legacies.
There were our names,
will we heralded in the future as a
person who cared more about other people
then they cared about themselves. That
is truly a Christian, a Buddhists,
uh, a zen like attitude. And I think that,
um, it's time for people to take
action. We need a revolution.
It is time. It's time for people to
take action. Could not agree more. Uh,
and you've given a number
of recommendations that I
will link to in the show
notes as usual. So everyone
listening, everything we've discussed,
all the links to everything
that US certainly that I
can track down and that my
team can track down.
We'll be in the show notes at
tim.blog/podcast for this episode.
And Paul,
you've been very generous with your time.
People can find you@fungi.com
fungi.net host defense.com
and on social media on Instagram.
You're Paul Stamets, Facebook,
Paul Stamets,
Youtube with Paul Stamets.
Is there a a for people who want
to know where to go for what?
Is there one best place
for certain things?
A certain best place to say hello? If
people want to reach out to you somehow,
oh, that's a complicated like,
did you tell him, you know,
we get so many people, why in
the contact us? But for the, I'm,
I want to feed some of the researchers
out there and people who want to get into
some of the detailed research articles.
We have a website that we populate
called mushroom risotto, mushroom,
references.com,
mushroom references.com.
I several hundred peer reviewed articles,
um,
that we linked to the abstracts that
talk about their most recent research of
the, uh, from mycelium. Um,
and as I'm and deep dive,
many physicians are unfamiliar and because
the public expects that there will be
experts about everything on health,
they're actually quite ignorant.
And so I have found this has been a
challenge is why I speak to a lot of, uh,
academic and a lot of academic conferences
that a lot of medical conferences is
that there is a desperate need by
these physicians to get on board and be
familiarized with some of the latest
research. So, um, but otherwise, you know,
fungi.com is a hub and we
have a resource section, uh,
at the end on that website that links
to many other, uh, nonprofits, uh,
lots of other resources, uh,
including, uh, Cornell University.
And I said particularly a good
one. Um, there is, uh, Miko Web,
which is extremely good. M, y.
K. O. W. E. B.
Michael Web's a really good one.
And I'm,
so there's a lot of my colleges out
there that are genuinely really,
really good people,
but they have,
I've in a sense have tasked them with
expectations greater than some of which
they can deliver. And I apologize for
that, but time is short, is every,
it's so important that everybody gets a
aboard the starship and, and try to do.
Good.
Well thank you so much
for your time today. Paul.
This has been really fun for
me and I'm sure for for many,
many people who are listening.
Is there anything else that you would
like to share or recommend before we wrap
up at least to this,
this first conversation on the podcast?
Yeah.
Um,
if you see somebody being
abused or somebody being shamed,
stop up,
extend a hand of generosity and
show people a better way of acting
here, here. So that is an
excellent way to wrap up. And, uh,
once again, Paul, a real pleasure
to spend this time with you.
I have pages and pages and pages of notes,
follow ups for myself and
for my family and also many
different avenues that I want to explore.
And to everyone listening to find the
show notes at tim.blog/podcast and until
next time, keep experimenting
and express some kindness.
It is time to take action. So get off of
the ear phones, get off of the ear buds,
get off of the pages in those
books that you might consume,
one after the other, and actually taping.
Take a meaningful step forward, uh, with,
with somehow bending the reality
around you in a positive direction.
And until next time, thanks
for listening. Hey guys,
this is Tim again. Just a few more
things before you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I found or that I've been pondering
over the week. That could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include a few articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which has the largest selection
of audio books on the planet.
I've used audible for many years and I've
several audio books to recommend right
off the bat. If you're looking for a new
one ready player, one by Ernest Cline,
he may have heard of it.
The Tao of Seneca Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite collection
of letters of all time as well as the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
which is a fiction book I
used to reintroduce nonfiction
purists to the beauty
and truth and enjoyment,
affection graveyard book.
It is incredible and I liked the
version that Neil reads himself,
but the entire ensemble cast is also fun.
Audible members get a credit every month,
good for any audio book in the store,
regardless of price and unused
credits roll over to the next month.
So if you didn't like your audio
book, no problem. You can exchange it,
no questions asked. Plus, your books
are yours to keep with audible.
You can go back and relisten anytime,
even if you cancel your membership
and for some books, again,
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
I've listened to many, many times.
You may even just start over as soon
as you finish it the first time.
Autobot also helps you to listen to more
books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices.
Picking up exactly where you left off,
whether it's on your phone,
through your car,
from a tablet or at
home on an Amazon Echo,
whatever you can get
through tons of books,
hands and eyes free while
doing almost anything.
So that is part of the beauty of audio.
It is a secondary activity when
you're walking the dog cooking,
whatever it might be.
Audible content includes an
unmatched selection of audiobooks,
original audio shows, news, comedy,
and much more from leading audio book
publishers, Broadcasters, Entertainers,
magazine and newspaper publishers
and business information providers.
Maybe that's what I am,
a business information provider and right
now audible is offering listeners of
this podcast a free audiobook with a
30 day trial memberships. Check it out.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim and
browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs. Download a title free and
start listening is super simple.
Go to audible.com forward slash 10 or
text Tim to 500 500 on your telephone to
get started today. Check it out. This
episode is brought to you by Peloton,
which I've been using
probably for about a year now.
Peloton is a cutting edge indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home. You can also
do on demand, which is what I do.
We'll come back to that so you don't have
to worry about fitting classes into a
busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute.
I for instance,
have a Peloton bike right in my master
bedroom at home and it's one of the first
things I do. Many mornings I
wake up and meditate for a bit.
Then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
in my undies. Hard to do that at the gym,
take a shower and I'm in higher
gear for the rest of the day.
It's really convenient and has become
something that I look forward to see.
You have a lot of options
for one if you'd like.
You can ride live with thousands of
other writers across the country on an
interactive leaderboard
to keep you motivated.
There are also up to 14 new classes added
every day with more than 8,000 classes
on demand and you can pick
based on length, 45 minutes,
20 minutes, whatever music,
hip hop, rock and roll or say low impact
versus high intensity or interval.
You can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case I
quite like Matt [inaudible] and I tend
to do on demand and listened to a lot of
and watch many of the same
classes over and over,
but I'm kind of promiscuous and also
enjoy classes from a lot of the other
instructors.
They have Peloton and amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles
and personalities so you
can find what you're in
the mood for.
You also get real time metrics that you
can use to track your performance over
time and that will help, I would say,
catalyze you to beat your personal best.
Now that all sounds good, right?
Gamification, Yada, Yada, Yada.
I didn't think that it would work
for me or in any way incentivize me,
but they really 100% hit the
nail on the head. I was very,
very impressed with how motivating
it was and it worked tremendously.
T keep me pushing, uh, which quite
honestly takes a fair amount.
I can get quite lazy, particularly
with anything that edges on endurance,
which is kind of more than five reps
of anything for me. So check it out.
Discover this cutting edge indoor cycling
bike that brings a studio experience
right to your home Peloton is offering
listeners of this podcast a limited time
offer. Go to one [inaudible]
dot com that's [inaudible], O,
n e Peloton p e l o t o
n.com and enter the code Tim,
all caps at checkout and get $100 off
of accessories with your policy on bike
purchase. So get a great workout at
home anytime you want. Check it out.
Go to one Peloton [inaudible] dot com
and use the code Tim, to get started.